Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
What's going on?
How I uh,
I am,
uh,
once again,
this is like all of a sudden I never have fucking guests and then all of a
sudden they all come out of the woodwork almost at the same time on all
musicians.
And once again,
we have a very special guest.
Ms Tal Wilkenfeld how are you?
I'm good.
You got a new album coming out.
Yup.
Right.
It just can't,
you know,
I didn't even want to start with that because I know you've fucking been talking
about all kinds of music I had asked you,
cause we over your place right now.
Well,
how are you liking the Vitamix?
I love the Vitamix because I got into like the,
I'm an old man now.
I don't know if he can tell.
I use a lot of lotion,
right?
They can still in my twenties,
but I'm about to turn 51 here in June.
And uh,
I,
I've started to do like for breakfast.
I like to just have like a smoothie.
Yeah.
His phone.
He's,
that sounds to everybody doesn't live in,
it's the fucking greatest thing ever,
right?
You just drink it.
You full.
Yeah.
You know,
rather than doing the Denny's grand slam breakfast,
you feel like a tub of shit,
which makes you eat something else bad.
So people been telling me about the [inaudible] mix and this is where I am in my
life right now.
I'm like,
like that was the thing.
You have all these amazing instruments and shit.
And the thing that stuck out was like,
Ooh,
if Vitamix,
I wonder if that one mashes up the fucking spinach and Kale a little bit better.
The best recipe to you do cause I got it.
I got two really good ones that I stand by.
What are they,
are they trade?
Uh,
I got one that uh,
I substitute the Kale for spinach.
Spinach tastes better.
All of this.
This is just,
it's a substitute for Dandelion Greens.
Just Fyi you with,
I use the landline Greens now.
What do you do to sweeten that up so it's not bitter as shit?
I used some honey just a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Yeah.
My one time my wife took me to some restaurant.
We ended up eating like Dan the lines like a downline.
We both try not like,
hey man,
let's be healthy.
We both looked at each other.
It's like,
oh,
it was one of the worst things I ever tasted.
So when you grind that up,
what do you have almond milk in there too?
Or Center?
It's actually a juice really.
It's not like a smoothie.
Um,
but it's quite thick,
which is why I still call it a smoothie,
but mine has Dandelion Greens,
Salon trow,
a little bit of black pepper.
Oh my God.
Tumeric.
Um,
ginger like fresh ginger,
which,
which you call me.
What you stand by that it's this sounds,
it sounds honey.
What else do I put it in their water?
There's obviously water and then I get hungry an hour and a half later.
Where do you buy Danny?
Go in your backyard and yanked them out of the fucking grass.
What do you,
what do you get your dental lint?
Any health food store?
Wholefoods or I've never said,
I gotta be honest with you.
And I've been to a few of those little health food places.
I've never,
I've never seen that.
But,
uh,
all right.
Mine.
Mine is just simple.
It's just the almond,
it's a almond milk with some almonds just in case there's not enough almond in
there that some spinach,
uh,
to fuck is a banana.
A little bit of ice.
Um,
I know I'm forgetting something.
So cinnamon or blueberries,
do you ever use blueberries?
No.
I gotta get a couple of goals because I basically have to go to smoothies and
I'm getting sick of them.
And then I have like this Greek yogurt parfait and I just sort of rotate that on
a three then I'm just,
I've had it,
you know,
like when you've been jamming with people too long,
you're like,
we need some new blood or something.
That's where I am with assuming me trying to steer it back to the music here.
So let's at least say the name of your incredible album that I only heard three
tracks of,
cause I couldn't figure out how to download it.
Um,
for those of you not familiar with Tal,
she's,
uh,
she's basically played with everybody and I promised her I wasn't going to bring
up all the past like,
hey man,
what was it like playing with this person?
But she's,
you know,
I MDB or she's played with literally everybody and you've basically been known
as this monster Bass player that can just play with anybody.
And,
uh,
your hidden talent of an unbelievable singing voice is finally displayed.
That that's what killed me when I listened to you.
Just played those three tracks for me,
aside from a course,
how up front,
you know,
the basis and all the mics,
which I'm loving.
Um,
I,
yeah,
I had no idea you could sing like that.
I kind of,
um,
I,
I've kept it quiet for awhile.
Like I started as a singer songwriter when I first picked up guitar and then,
um,
sort of started focusing just on guitar when I moved to America because I left
home when I was 16 and I moved to America and I went to this music school for a
little while and,
uh,
I went from like
help you went to a nice place,
all this crap about the Michael Jackson documentary,
which I refuse to fucking watch.
Why would you do that?
Why would you put all those that those horrible stories in your head?
It's like,
I get it.
All right.
The guy was a creep,
but now he's dead.
So
what are we doing?
I guess you got to list somebody going,
someone was telling me going,
you,
how will you have to watch it?
So then you,
you as a parent,
it's like,
I'm not gonna let some fucking guys sleep with my kid behind nine doors anyways,
so you've got this album coming out.
So I went to,
um,
I went to this,
this school and I went from being allowed to play like half an hour a day to
wanting to practice for like six hours a day.
Was that torture for you,
considering the way you took?
I remember hearing,
yeah,
I watched that interview.
You said the first time you actually played a chord,
you got emotional,
you cried.
Yeah.
So you love something that much and then all of a sudden you go into,
you're going to school in Australia.
Yeah.
So they would teach you about Columbus and all the great stuff that happened
here in America of course.
Right.
Um,
whatever it was,
how you guys,
you got dropped off by the English and that what happened?
Something like that where a bunch of convicts apparently.
Yeah,
exactly.
So then all of a sudden,
was that torture for you in school?
It was just,
yeah,
it was hard because,
um,
you know,
academia was the focus,
especially like,
um,
where I like with who I grew up with.
Yeah.
Um,
my mom just like really wanted me to,
uh,
you know,
[inaudible] yeah,
I do all my schoolwork and stuff.
I mean,
she's probably just being a responsible parent,
but like I just was not into geography and history.
I was
so,
did you ever just like to pick up the bass and be like,
mom,
listen to this.
I mean,
I went to this and then look at my grades in math and you tell me which
direction I'm supposed to go in.
I mean,
uh,
I was just,
I was a guitarist at that point.
Like I only switched to bass when I was 17,
which,
and I already moved to America at that point.
But yeah,
I mean,
she heard me play.
I just,
I think that like,
you know,
uh,
the music business is a tough place and she probably just thought like,
oh,
maybe,
maybe that's not the best thing for you to do,
to be in the music industry.
It's so uncertain.
Um,
so,
but I wasn't going to listen to what anyone was going to say.
Like,
that's all I knew that I had to be a musician and I didn't care if I was going
to be homeless and right and be a musician.
I just,
I knew that that's what I had to do.
So
have you ever wonder how many this,
how many musicians are out there?
Because that story is like,
you had that inner drive and like I always wondered like,
how many like Jimi Hendrix or like working at home depot because their parents
or,
or some something,
you know,
they just didn't have that thing to be like,
no,
fuck that.
I'm doing it.
Right.
Um,
when really important people that basically taught you how to walk and talk and
all of that stuff,
start telling you,
you know,
you shouldn't go in that direction.
Is,
that's just something that you,
is,
was that something that developed?
Was it the love that you had when you started playing guitar that you will like,
no,
I literally have to do this?
Or do you feel you always had sort of that,
that,
uh,
that drive?
Yeah.
Well,
I actually think,
um,
as a kid,
especially as a teenager,
like if your parents tell you not to do something,
you're going to want to do it more like 99% of teenagers I dread those days.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Yeah.
So it probably worked,
uh,
out in the right way that she didn't really want me to focus on music because
that just made me want to do it more.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm kind of,
I wouldn't even say I was necessarily rebellious,
but if you want something in that bad and someone's telling you no,
you're like,
well,
I'll prove to you that I really deserve this and I'm gonna work my ass off.
And I did,
like,
I was so focused,
like my rebellion as a teenager was to succeed as a musician.
It wasn't like to go off and do drugs or whatever else.
Like that was my rebellion was
who is success.
You know,
I went to,
I was looking at schools to see which one to take,
you know,
put my daughter in,
all the public schools and shit out here.
I guess so you got to send them to private school and spend like a zillion
dollars by the time in like eight.
It's so fucking stupid.
So he went to this one and it was like a French speaking one,
right?
So all the kids was amazing.
The kids were super smart as a great score and,
and,
but the lady given like the tour,
right?
She goes,
uh,
the hell did she say?
I asked her,
I said,
hey,
you know,
uh,
did the parents kind of learned French along the way?
She's like,
no,
we,
we encourage you to speak the perfect English at home and blah,
blah.
I said,
well,
what if I bought,
if I want to learn it too?
And she looked at me,
she goes,
yes,
it's too late.
I was just like,
God damn,
I actually respected it,
but you know what?
I'm so happy she said that to me because now I've got this thing.
Like,
all right,
I'll show you.
Yeah.
And I got flashcards.
I would have flash cards and I'm like looking at,
and I'm trying to put together phrases and stuff.
I listened the back of my head,
I know she's probably right and I loved the school and I'm actually excited that
the potential to go there.
But like I do relate to that as far as,
um,
when somebody says that,
but there was a period in my life where I wasn't that guy.
Like if somebody said that to me,
I'd be like,
okay,
forget it.
Oh really?
So yeah,
I've probably had that since I was really young.
Like,
like just determination to do whatever I want to do.
Cause like I remember being super focused on,
um,
running before I was a guitar player and I was like obsessed with long distance
running.
Like,
and,
and in my head I'm like,
I have to be the best.
I have to be the best runner,
gold from Australia.
One girl that was better than me and it pissed me off so much.
And I remember like,
there was this one race that was,
I dunno,
it was like a 10 mile race.
It was really long and,
and I just,
I just had to beat this,
go.
And I did beat the girl.
You did.
But I did this like,
um,
like still liberatory dance afterwards because I was so excited and I threw my
back out and um,
yeah.
So then I,
I kind of was like hobbling around for a little while and couldn't run a couple
of weeks and then that's actually when I walked past that guitar and started
playing,
get this out.
Right.
Yeah.
Wow.
She get mad when you did that dance.
I mean,
I don't think she saw it.
She was that far behind me.
Wow.
That's like a feel good movie.
Except they,
they always run credits before you blow out your back.
Then you became like a musician.
So,
you know,
the,
the few tracks that I heard in the three,
the three that I listened to is definitely,
you know,
this is really like a very personal album as far as like,
talking about yourself to that one you just played.
What was the name of the haunted heart?
I wanted love haunted love.
The one that's just the base and voice with the orchestra.
Yeah.
That was some pretty,
uh,
heavy lyrics that made me start thinking about my parents.
I went on a little trip there.
One of those.
Yeah.
Thinking about my whole life and um,
I fo people listening here,
I can't recommend like the level of quality of,
of the music that you've,
you've done with other people now to actually hear,
hey these are my ideas with your voice on top of it.
Uh,
the second I heard you a few of these,
I was like,
oh this is one of these,
these albums I'm just going to put in back in the day when he had a CD.
Just stick it in there until the thing just uh,
started skipping on you.
But um,
you mean how your iTunes that skipping on you right now?
He like,
I know I am the worst.
I'm the worst before all you can download it.
You got Spotify.
It's like I don't have Spotify.
I,
I'm,
I'm this idiot who I still buy music and then it fills up your computer and now,
cause right now I need a new,
I need a new laptop.
I need a new phone and an Ipod,
iPad,
the whole thing,
shit in the bed on me at the same time.
And uh,
yeah,
I miss,
can I buy it on vinyl?
I,
yeah,
I have a record player.
Yes.
I'll even give it to you on vine.
They don't need to do that.
You already got me a Burrito here from coming over,
so I'll,
I'll,
I'll throw some money towards that,
but um,
wasn't gonna say.
So you also mentioned that you're actually going to be doing a whole tour in
this thing too,
Huh?
Yeah.
Now headlining tour.
You open and what are you doing?
Headlining headline in.
Nice.
I'm excited.
And I got to Boston.
Is this your first like big headlining tour?
Cause you've always been like the hired gun.
Um,
as far as I know,
this is your first like,
um,
well I,
I actually,
I was opening for the who with my band and we played the Boston Garden and some
really cool,
is it called the bus and garden?
They called the TD bank north garden keyed.
How'd you like that?
That was fun.
Then you do that recently?
Uh,
yeah,
I did some stand up there and I did jam before with my brothers.
So cool.
Uh,
we had a good,
yeah,
we definitely heard a
[inaudible] ever.
No one was paying attention at all and we were playing or whatever.
They thought it was kind of funny that we were doing it.
And this is comedian,
not Jim brewer who does this amazing pit on slayer fans,
like how dedicated and crazy they are or we actually play it.
I forget what song we played.
We played a slayer song and literally it was like no one was reacting to
anything we were doing.
We sucked right.
The second we started playing slayer,
some fucking security guide like you know,
halfway up the renewed just goes slayer.
It was hilarious.
So,
um,
now your style of music like going,
no,
you're going to ask me something that was going to say like,
like what does playing before a standup set do for you?
It makes the,
the venue not as intimidating.
I've only done it at like what?
Because you know,
it stand up in a place that big doesn't make sense.
You like highlight,
you know,
I,
I had all these feelings of like,
why am I a,
like how did I get here?
What am I doing here?
What the fuck do I have to say that justifies all these people showing up,
you know,
the normal,
if you're any sort of like human being,
that's what you have.
If you're a psychopath,
you just like,
yeah,
how come I'm not playing the football stadium or whatever,
you know,
I've ever playing the Roman Colosseum.
But I,
yeah,
I was sitting there and uh,
that's that what was,
what was going through my head.
But,
um,
the first time I ever did one I did for the New York comedy festival and I did
Madison Square Garden and,
uh,
we got together and jammed in there and I just did that because I love led
Zeppelin and they did song remains the same.
I,
if I could just play some drums there and make a little bit of noise.
And what happened was we were having so much fun and I invited so many people
down there,
they,
I,
you know,
I didn't ever fully forget where I was,
but next thing you know,
you know,
I was yelling,
Hey Josh,
John is at that Motley crew thing and you just,
you just yelling and you just kind of made it yours.
Yeah.
So that night it just didn't,
it didn't feel,
um,
I was able to kind of just like,
I had already made a bunch of noise in there and nothing bad happened.
You know,
we didn't enough the roof collapse.
So I think that that's kind of like what it did for me.
Although I fucked up at the form cause I played it like three hours.
I almost fucked up cause I was just like,
I got off stage and I was like wiped out.
I was just like,
oh no.
Oh No.
But then like the adrenaline is like,
oh my God,
what if I bombing from all these fucking people?
You know,
that that'll get you through a good 90 [inaudible].
But why do you not like play on stage for your audience?
Because I respect them.
Ah,
you're a great drummer.
I didn't know why you say that.
Uh,
I'm good for a comedian.
I'll give you that.
But I am not a,
you know what I,
I like,
uh,
like one of my favorite things to do is to watch a pro play cause it's just,
you know,
when they're just doing like a sound check,
a lot of times there'll be physically playing something that I could play,
but I could never make it sound like that.
And there's always like a personnel,
you know,
if you listen to a really good drama,
you can hear like you can hear them in the plane,
which,
um,
you know,
took me a while to be able to hear that.
But,
uh,
now I'm able to do,
and I've,
I've,
I've seen,
I don't know,
there's just something cool about it.
It's like watching a professional hockey player,
like taping up the stick.
There's just something,
when you see a pro doing something,
um,
it's,
and your into it,
especially if it's your hobby,
it's fucking mesmerizing.
So that's,
that's why when a few times I've come over here,
like I'm always in there cause I'm like sitting back and just watching all of
you guys play.
And um,
my favorite thing about watching a live band is watching a band that doesn't
play it the same way every night and you,
and even if you've never seen the band you can tell cause they like looking at
each other and everything.
So that's when I get into like,
Oh man,
they're in the moment right now.
This is like watching a comic riff and somebody's going to do something to make
somebody smile and then he adds something else tonight.
And just as an audience member and a fan of music trying to pick up like that
thing going on and um,
and like my,
I in turn,
like I'm the bands I listened to growing up.
Like I remember Stevie Ray Vaughan whenever he was playing a solo,
it was like Chris Layton and Tommy Shannon and Reese will always looking right
at him.
Like,
is he going to go back in again?
All we go and we going back to the,
you know,
him singing and he just would fucking be wailing.
And he had this little thing.
You just look at him,
he gives him a little nod and how they all were like,
okay.
And,
and,
and they wouldn't fuck that up.
I'm just having attempted to Gino get together with friends and play and
everything.
I just,
I've,
I have such an admiration for it.
So,
um,
I mean that's how I feel about comedy in great comedy.
And that's why I like watching you perform.
Oh yeah.
When I do a great shit joke and I not over to somebody who just did a dick joke
and it's amazing.
It's right on the same level.
No,
but like,
cause I just started as,
you know,
like getting really heavily into comedy to pass like a year or so.
Yeah.
And like the reason it appeals to me so much is because it like speaks to both
parts of me as a musician.
There's the,
uh,
the jazz musician in me,
which is like the improvisational musician,
which like,
like really enjoys watching you ref like,
and,
and just,
and then there's like,
then there's like the composer,
like the person that's like,
you know,
into writing songs and like,
and then watching you create this amazing materials.
So it's,
it's very satisfying a requirement for people in your band.
Cause I mean,
when you work,
when you go and do this tour,
like,
uh,
I,
I just know doing the same jokes over and over and over again.
It's like you have to like,
do something to break out of it.
Do you,
um,
on this tour,
I mean,
you sell on the album,
you got to go out and,
and,
you know,
play it and sell the music to them.
Like how,
how much,
like messing around do you do?
I do a lot and then is a requirement and that's why it's been really tricky to
find band members.
And I have found like the perfect,
um,
guitarist and a drummer to play with me because,
you know,
my music is a composition.
Lee.
Um,
like lyrically for instance,
very influenced by folk music or just songwriter music.
But then musically it's,
um,
it's influenced from anything from rock to folk to jazz to whatever.
It just goes all over the place.
That's what I was loving.
But this,
there's some sort of through line.
Maybe it's you,
I don't know what it is on because I was just listening to that song was so
great and then I really started listening to the mix of it.
I'm like,
wow,
she's the whole bottom end of this song.
And then it felt like,
I don't know how to say technically,
but it felt like the guitars and keys were like up here and,
but you were the sort of the meat and potatoes of the whole thing driving the
whole song,
but like the,
uh,
the different tones and stuff.
Um,
there was why I'm,
I'm,
I'm the worst.
I don't know the names of the,
the one,
yeah.
When you went into that bridge that was [inaudible] is that with sections called
at Middlesex was just like,
what the fuck is that?
And then you go right back to that part that really rocks.
When I looked at you,
I was just like,
that's when the crowd's going to go nuts.
Cause you take them on this ride where you coming out and you just,
you know,
blowing their wig back in the beginning and then it goes to this other places
like,
Whoa,
what the fuck is this?
This is this mood thing.
Well that's where it's like,
hey,
people start taking the drugs in the crowd.
I would feel,
and
look,
and I went,
I went to what you'll be doing.
That's what I do.
I grew up going to heavy metal cards.
That was a time,
all of a sudden somebody like sparked up a fucking J is we used to say and uh,
and then all of a sudden like out of nowhere,
you just punch him in the face again and then the fucking song is over.
It's just like,
yeah.
Um,
I think that the cohesiveness,
um,
on the record comes from like having the same band play all of these songs,
even though they've,
they're very different.
Like,
some are,
you know,
just vocal and base and some of our acoustic guitar and,
and very,
uh,
little,
behind me.
And then there's like these full rockers but it's the same band and I just think
that that's really important.
Like for how long does it take you to put that together?
Well,
it took me a few years to sort of search for the sound of the record and like
figure out who was going to play on it and who,
who like what was the,
the best sound for these songs.
And then I finally went into the studio with the Blake mills and Jeremy and
polls Stacy and uh,
we cut corner painter,
which is the first song I played you in as the first song on the record.
And that when I heard that back on the speakers,
and this was no base,
it was just,
I was playing acoustic baritone guitar.
Blake was playing guitar and Jeremy was playing drums and the sound was so full,
I didn't even want to play bass on it.
There's no bass on that song at all.
I just played it on an organ.
And then Ben Montench overdubbed a organ as well,
like a pump organ.
But I heard that song was like this is the lynch pin for the record.
And so then I went home and I like wrote a bunch of other songs that I felt
would fit with that vibe or compliment it.
And then once I'd done that,
we went back in the studio for,
it was like anywhere from like eight to 10 days and cut the whole thing at once.
And so I think that that's part of the cohesiveness is that we just,
we cut it all together.
All right.
When you've put together a band,
have you ever had been like,
okay,
I know these two people are right and then a third person comes in and so takes
it into another direction.
You got to fire one of those other two people that just cause,
but the other kids,
the other person's such a beast.
I mean it's all,
it's all about Canada pointed at the drums when I said that.
Right now it's all about chemistry.
It's like casting for a movie too.
Like,
sometimes it's the most important thing is the casting.
All right.
How do you like your lay by the way?
I Miss Australia.
Um,
I don't Miss Australia.
some of my best friends are there.
I definitely miss them,
you know,
but,
and I miss the beach.
I didn't really think that the beach in La is that cool?
No,
I gotta be,
I'm terrified of the ocean and,
but every time I go to Australia,
it's like I,
if I was ever,
you know,
there's a place to get eaten by a shark.
It is definitely the coasts of your country.
It's so beautiful.
You'd beat me as well.
At least I was,
you know,
at least you dive beautifully.
Yeah,
I remember we were there in like a,
I don't know when we were,
was your,
your weird winter down there,
which is just the different time.
And it was too,
it was too cold and windy.
Um,
it's not weird.
It's just weird to me cause I'm in the northern hemisphere,
but so we were down there and I was expecting it to be fucking hot and all of a
sudden it was like freezing and uh,
but even then I was looking at and I was like,
if it wasn't so rough and it wasn't so cold,
I think I would add maybe I did actually go into the water when I was in Perth
because I just wanted to say that I stood in the Indian Ocean.
I literally went up to my ankles and I got back in and then I got in the car and
I was listening to the radio and there was a helicopter following and like an 18
foot tiger shark along the beach just to let the surfers and everybody know that
the thing was there.
And you guys had the creepiest terminology ever for when someone gets eaten by a
shark,
you say he was taken.
That's what I heard.
Oh yeah,
it was a something blah,
blah,
blah.
He got taken.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'd rather be eaten than taken.
Eaten to me is,
it's over.
I mean it's fucking horrific and that you bleed out and it's over.
Taken means I,
you took me somewhere.
I just started thinking a chainsaw massacre when that fucking guy just grabbed
that woman a yanked her and slammed the door.
So taking almost sounds slightly more polite though.
Not taken well I guess what the next word is taken to the movies.
Right,
exactly.
Taken into the fucking movies by some sharks.
Oh yeah,
I was going to say,
you know,
it seems a,
you know what,
I liked it.
This fair play on this album.
Yeah.
As far as a,
there was a few where it was the other person and that was a few.
There was you.
All right.
So that's a a,
that's a,
that's an important milestone in your life when you,
the,
at least for me it was when I was able to be like,
alright,
you know,
I was going through that dude chicks a fucking Psychos,
I did that till I was about 35 and I was just like,
all right Phil,
you know,
at what point are you going to fucking is,
it may be you maybe who you're picking maybe what you're bringing to the table.
And then once I was able to do that,
I finally ended up meeting Nia.
I,
that's kind of why I called the album love remains because love remains as in
the remanence of love.
Like the aftermath of,
of a love gone bad or love remains,
I love still exists.
Oh I thought you went,
there was still pieces of other relationships in you.
It's both.
It's like the remnants and then love still,
you know,
continues.
There's always love.
Well,
this is theory among my guy friends that women are able to cry it out cause
you're allowed to cry,
that you're able to get passionate and then it's just like fucking gone.
Where guys like hang on to shit.
I mean,
I was reading this book on Bob Cousy,
he was one of the Great Celtics and Bill Russell,
right?
One of the greatest players of all time.
And Bob Cousy,
his wife passed away and he still has a picture on the wall and he still talks
to her.
I guess they didn't break up.
So maybe it was that.
But like,
you know,
I used to always joke with my wife going,
if I died within three weeks,
should have all my clothes down at goodwill,
you keep me having a DVD in the back of a fucking closet where she's like,
no,
I would never do though.
But I just feel like women are better at,
uh,
e how you're wired.
And then I also think it's more,
it's,
uh,
one of the great emotions crying when the great healing emotions is not
acceptable for guys and you just shut it off.
So not only do not get to heal,
you actually make yourself,
I think worse by fucking,
uh,
holding it in.
It's bad enough.
You know?
I don't know.
It's,
it's a really a weird thing.
So,
uh,
that's a,
that's actually,
I don't,
I don't know what the word is,
but to hear you say that,
that,
that you actually,
uh,
some of it stays in there.
I don't know if that makes me feel not as fucked up.
Nah.
We'll also,
like,
I,
I feel like when
when you're in love or when you love someone,
like
people often like projected outwards as if it's the other person that's making
you in love,
whereas like love is actually just always in you and that that person is,
is maybe igniting it or oh,
is showing you that it's there,
but it is always there.
And knowing that keeps me centered.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's not something that you can,
it's hard to remember that,
you know,
I would,
I would say,
I don't know,
I'm actually literally getting uncomfortable just even talking about it.
It helps me.
I was walled off for a long fucking time and then I,
I had like this massive amount of love in me and he would just come out in these
weird ways like about like,
like,
uh,
animals being abused or any sort of person being hurt.
I could feel it,
but like if I was just with somebody and we're going to the movies,
like I didn't even know what the fuck to do.
I just be sitting there like this fucking robot.
Like,
did you enjoy that?
Now we're getting on the subway.
And it was just like,
and I was meeting people.
I,
I just,
uh,
I know you,
I'm embarrassed at where the kind of person I was back in the day as far as like
trying to get through stuff like that.
But how did you break through that?
I met somebody I couldn't break up with.
I would in my head fantasize during tough times of breaking up with my now wife
and in my head we were living in this place where there was,
there was the first place was an elevating.
They'll twice had stairs and when she was going to get on the elevator,
even in the fantasy of being single again before the door close,
I would run out and go get her or when she would walk down the stairs at all
right.
I come back in like I couldn't eat.
I couldn't even an a for years.
I did that and it never dawned on me like I've always been so fucking like not
in touched with like,
hey bill,
you know,
this is the 20,000 fucking signal.
Like I used to ride around.
I had a paper back in the day and I used to ride around in the morning and I had
memorized comedy routines of my favorite comedians and I would fantasize that I
was doing them in front of the school and it didn't dawn on me at that point.
They hit bill.
Maybe you want to be a comedian.
It didn't.
It was just,
I had no connection to it whatsoever.
Huh.
It was just me.
I think at that point it was all about,
you know,
getting people to like me so I wouldn't get the shit kicked out of me or I
wouldn't have to deal with some,
you know,
was,
it was,
it was before all this carrying on social media is just like,
they'll,
the host every day at school was just like,
am I going to get it today or is,
or how can I get it off of me and get it onto the next week?
His kid who was a very weird,
um,
I dunno,
some of it was good,
but a lot of it wasn't a necessarily,
probably the way kids should grow up now.
We're probably like overly doing it.
I don't know.
You don't make me feel good when you came,
when I came into place here and you were like,
oh,
there's my phone.
If,
if I lose my phone all the
time,
oh my gosh,
you have massive add.
I also unfortunately get phone anxiety,
which I hate.
Like,
Oh,
you don't have it,
right.
Yeah.
If I don't have it,
I start to like feel like,
oh shit,
where's the phone?
Or like if I don't look at it for,
for,
for too long I started to feel that and so I have to work really hard at like
disciplining myself so that I can like keep it away from me for a certain amount
of hours to be like creative and productive.
Cause it's just PR.
Like I feel so sorry for like for kids that are like teenagers right now.
Like they just like so attached to their phones and I see what it does to my
brain.
Teenager I am.
That was brutal.
Yeah.
Not like gives you the shortest attention span it like everything's just
immediate.
And so I'm just so glad that like,
uh,
it kind of came a little bit later.
You realize we're like lab rats cause we're like sort of the first wave of like,
well let's see what this does to people.
I actually saw,
you know,
I went and I got gas today and I saw this to the Burrito or no,
well that's going to be later.
That's what,
this podcast will not be a full hour whenever you'll know what's hitting me,
what the fuck is on the microphones that are here in fucking nuts,
piece of fuzz.
Um,
so I went up to that still there.
See this is the podcast.
People are used to ghetto.
Um,
so I pulled up to get,
I was getting pumping gas and you know,
this la couple pulls up la meaning beautiful.
I'm not judging them like they're assholes to fucking beautiful rope.
So they pull up and the guy gets out to pump the gas.
The woman's driving the second she barely prospect park,
you know,
the immediately the phone and was just sitting there and I was watching her and
I was just like,
that's me.
That is literally me.
I do that when I'm driving like a lot.
I know.
Fucking terrible.
It's,
yeah,
I called a friend up one time,
this is maybe about three months ago.
I was trying to do like an intense period of writing and I said,
hey,
could you just cause I'm,
you know,
it takes like,
I think apparently 28 days to break a habit.
I said,
can you come over for,
you know,
28 days apparently as a kid,
you can I give you my phone and then just go away and then I'll meet you back
here.
And I did that for a few days and actually like helped me like reprogram myself.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And like once you do that,
then it's like,
ah,
you feel like you can finally relax.
It's weird.
This is something that I learned going overseas and I can't get texts from
anybody.
This is what happens if you don't text anybody.
Nobody texts you.
Like I would come back thinking,
oh my God,
I haven't checked my text messages in 10 days.
I'm going to have 5 million fucking texts.
And I had like maybe six,
seven.
Yeah.
I don't want,
am I a loser?
Nobody like I don't text people.
You're like,
no,
I come back to a zillion of them now.
I feel like an asshole.
No,
I came back and it's like you,
uh,
it's,
it's like,
you know,
like ones do you want something in your life not to happen
and you don't realize how much of it you're creating.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
so much of the phone shit,
I realize I am creating all of the texting that I'm doing.
Like I'm in traffic.
Traffic sucks.
I just start calling people.
Right.
I'm just like,
hey man,
what's going on?
I'm stuck on the fuck.
I literally have a friend of mine that we like we our friendship cause she's
married with kids.
I'm married,
didn't have a kid.
It was just like our whole relationship.
I don't think I've seen her in a year and a half.
Our relationship that we have the deal,
the,
an unwritten deal is that we call each other when we're stuck in traffic.
Yeah.
Then the big joke is,
hey,
I'm on the one 35.
Hey,
I'm on the one on one.
Yup.
And then that's in the or the other person picks up.
All right,
where are you?
How long a drive do you have?
And it's just like,
you're sort of almost like a suicide hotline,
talking them to get home.
I do like all of my phone calls in the car to or um,
really,
really late at night.
Like while I'm getting ready for bed.
Like,
like my friends in Australia just know that I'm going to call it like 3:00 AM my
time.
Like facetiming them while I'm like brushing my teeth and shit.
And now it's like a ritual.
Like,
oh,
are you ready for teeth brushing time
and what is it like seven the next day they're right.
Seven at night,
14 year olds or even slightly.
Yeah,
something like that.
around,
around about then it's great that guy,
I always call Australia at that time when I'm getting ready for bed time.
That was the last time you heard some music that that made you?
Uh,
like whenever I listened to like amazing music,
I always fantasize that it's me doing it.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I do that on all the way through the song.
If the drums are awesome,
I'm playing drums,
someone singing great,
then all of a sudden I'm doing that.
I'm very self involved.
When was the last time you as a musician listened to something and you were just
like,
ah fuck,
I wish that was me.
Does that happen?
I don't know.
It doesn't happen but strike too with the texting and now fantasy,
the fantasizing.
I don't do that but I,
I listened to admire a lot of people.
Who Do you listen to coming up?
I didn't want to ask you any of these questions.
I know you've been asked this man.
Fuck.
I listened to miles Davis and then of course there was the bgs,
jazz disco.
I just,
you know what I'm really obsessed with is his Indian classical music.
Do you remember that time?
We were like driving back from one of your shows and I played you some Indian
Indian classical music.
I played you,
I remember we were meeting and me and Josh were singing some Song Bob Dylan Song
to you,
which you really didn't like or you are making fun of.
But Bob Dylan is like one of my favorites of all time.
I love Bob doing okay.
But like you were like joking around like changing the lyrics and stuff.
I was just being an ass.
I was fine with me if we do that all the time.
But you made me laugh so much and then I played you in Indian classical piece
but maybe you don't remember that.
But what I remember you playing that Blues Song.
Yeah,
that was blind Willie Johnson.
Yes.
Also one of my faves.
Okay.
Yeah,
that I remember.
Yeah.
I love old blues.
Like it's so raw and real.
Right.
And I also like,
like,
cause if you,
you'll notice like on my album,
like I switch in and out of like time signatures a lot and,
but it doesn't sound like I'm switching time secrets.
She's at least that's what I do tell us the things that I yeah,
I didn't really notice that,
but that's what I'm saying.
Like because I kind of,
I let the music,
um,
like the melody or the story guide the time as opposed to like the other way
around.
Like,
sometimes people will write the music first and then that lay the melody and
stuff on top.
Oh,
I saw an interview with somebody said that said every time I come up with the
riff,
it's in a weird time signature and then the drummer fixes it.
And I remember thinking like,
this should've fucking kept it.
Right.
Getting that.
Yeah,
but like fuck do I know.
But I'm just saying that that's what I,
that's what I would think.
Yeah.
Like I was joking around like with uh,
with Bob Weir because like basically he,
he played with Lightening Hopkins.
Bob,
we're here shooting grateful dead right now.
He played with lightening.
Hopkins is one of my favorite like blues players.
And um,
I know when he started,
like those guys were all like in their forties,
right?
Yeah.
Guys at me.
And he was joking around like saying that like lightening played like the 12 and
a half bar blues because you know,
if he has to add a beat to finish the story,
he's telling me he's going to add a beat.
Like it's not about like just this rigid thing.
And like I was,
I've been composing like that too.
Like if the melody wants to go on a few beats longer or you know,
then make it a buyer seven like,
and it will feel natural if it goes with the melody.
But if you try to fit a melody over the top of the time signature than sometimes
it can feel a little bit more um,
choppy.
Yeah,
I get that.
because then it's the cause to the lay person.
They're not listening what time it says no,
they're just following the melody and the story.
And it's the same with that old folk music too.
Like you listen to some of the old folk like you hear like bars of five and
seven cause it just adding beats to like finish the phrase.
I know I never noticed and that's sometimes why like you know,
they won't be drums on it.
Like if there was drums it,
it probably would sound kind of strange,
but it's just like an acoustic guitar and a voice.
Like that song I played for you,
that Bob Dylan Song,
it's called,
it's all right mom,
any bleeding.
Like there's some bars have like five and shit in that.
He just like add some beets and as you were you wouldn't know it but if you
counted it,
it's odd because he's just trying to fit the lyric in.
Ah,
yeah,
it's genius.
I love it.
How hello can be so talented in that area.
Like when,
when did,
when did you notice that shit?
Like I would just be like,
I'm just psyched if I listen to a song,
I know all the words.
I wouldn't be like,
oh that was just in seven
when I first moved to America and I was playing guitar.
I and I was like starting to play like six hours a day and I like gave myself a
tendinitis and I had to stop playing for a minute and then I started like,
like messing around like with drums with one hand or like base with one hand.
And people started coming up to me being like,
yeah,
mini Vinny,
Vinny,
Vinny.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is many Vinny,
you know,
of any color Uda.
Uh,
okay.
So I went and like listened to Vinnie Khalida,
this is me at I guess like 17 now and uh,
and everyone was passing around tapes of,
of Vinny color you'd like all like the stuff with charisma and um,
just a bunch of other stuff.
And uh,
and actually Vinnie was then one of the first people I met when,
when I moved to America because he came to my school and I'd been playing for
two and a half months at the time.
And like one of the,
the these drum clinicians was friends with him.
Wait a minute,
you don't even play in two and a half months if somebody told you to move to no
base space.
Cause I'd been playing guitar for a couple of years.
Yeah.
What was that like?
And he was like,
oh,
we should play some time.
I said,
yeah.
And I was so shy,
like,
because I listened to all this stuff and obviously his,
he's one of the best in the world and I was,
but I kept it in my head.
I'm like,
okay,
okay.
But then I moved to New York and I was like,
I just want to be a jazz musician.
I want to like play in clubs like five times a night.
And like Charlie Parker and monk and the guys did.
And,
and I did that for a few years.
And then that's when like,
I,
uh,
played with the Allman brothers and like made a record,
played with the almond brothers.
That was my first Gig when I was a teenager.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Christ.
Like that's where it all started.
And then I came back to La and I like played Vinnie this stuff with the Allman
brothers and my,
um,
my solo project.
And,
uh,
and then the weeks later he got the call from Jeff Beck that like,
Oh,
hit Jeff Beck's management that they needed a bass player.
And then he,
he told them about me and then they called me and they asked me to send in
tapes.
I sending in the tapes and the next thing I knew I was flying to England to
audition for Jeff.
So,
and then everything like,
you know,
prince and her whole,
you,
um,
I think I was 21 when I started playing with Jeff.
Yeah,
he's correct.
That's the first time I saw you live at Ronnie Scott's,
which I've still never been in.
Another couple of times I've gone to London.
I always assumed it's always like packed.
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
I want to go in there and just,
yeah,
have a drink,
an extra,
listen to some music for like two sites the first time I saw you.
So were you nervous when you went into the audition?
Um,
well I was food poisoned.
I just got enough of plain like where the,
and Vinnie went to the airport and I ate some barbecue chicken pizza and I got
on the plane and Vinnie is like raving on about politics because he's obsessed
with politics and I'm like,
hey Vinny,
I'm feeling kind of sick.
And uh,
he's like,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
so then this happened and you know,
I mean,
he kind of reminds me of you and you're writing me of him.
He was from,
uh,
he's from like Pennsylvania.
Oh,
is he?
Yeah.
Oh No.
Yeah,
Pittsburgh.
Oh,
he's from Pittsburgh as a Pittsburgh guy.
you went to Berkeley.
That's why I knew there was some sort of Massachusetts from there.
Yeah.
But anyway,
he's going on about politics.
And then meanwhile I just like throw up in a bag and I'm like,
there it is.
He's like,
yeah,
what is,
I'm like,
I'll see you in 10 hours.
And I was so sick that like,
then I had to let get rushed to the hospital and we landed and like be on a
drip.
And then the next day I auditioned for Jeff and so I was feeling really
weird.
But um,
talk about the worst fucking place to get food poisoning.
Oh my God.
Did they?
Oh,
but the audition went well because at that point I was so like woozy that I was
just like,
okay,
let's get through this.
Yeah.
And then that was the point where like Jeff pointed to me and said,
solo on,
cause we've ended his lovers and like he ended up loving that so much that he
like kept it in the set.
And that's how he was like featuring me every night.
Oh Wow.
How that
like a cool of him totally sharing who he is and all of that stuff too,
to like,
uh,
I love when people do stuff like that.
There's a lot of comedians that I,
you know,
um,
that I'm a fan of.
But what really makes me,
you know,
over the top is when I see them like encouraging and helping out,
pick comics that are coming up.
Cause I,
I hate that fucking thing of,
uh,
you know,
that behavior people will get to a certain level,
then they start treating,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm here and you're there.
It's all stupid.
It's just like,
it's,
you know,
you're great like that.
Like the way that you kind of mentor younger comedians by,
I mean,
I,
I try not to be in it.
I mean,
I remember most people were nice,
but I definitely remember who the people who weren't necessarily the names,
but I just remember what,
how that made me feel.
So it's,
it's sorta the same thing too.
Um,
both being like a parent and stuff.
I remember the good days at school and I remember the bad day,
so I remember how much fun it was playing with the other kids at school.
And then I also remember how bad it was if you know you wore the wrong shirt or
whatever and it's just,
it was just your day to take the pounding and just like how you could just
literally beginning that was literally like your world.
And that's something that I'm hoping I'm going to be able to remember.
Um,
which I think I Willis as Mike,
my kids going through school as far as uh,
knowing that though,
I mean those days,
I mean who the hell knows with all the fucking cameras out there,
I don't know if you get a little gift,
anything.
My buddy was just telling me,
you know,
some key told this story where there was some kid everybody picked on that day
and then the kids who picked on him,
they found out who all of them were and they had to go see the fucking
psychologists and shit.
And I was really thinking about that.
It's just like,
wow man.
Like nobody,
like there was none of that at all.
Like the guidance counselor was just some Weirdo down the hall and he would
just,
he just would talk to,
he would only really talk to kids who had no hope of going to college.
Right.
And he'd just be down.
They're like,
well,
hey man,
you know,
like maybe a,
you get into construction,
you know?
I mean,
I never even talked to him.
I just,
I don't know what he talked to them about maybe their home lives and shit.
Maybe it was like a therapy thing,
but like,
only the fucked up kids,
God guidance.
Right.
It was weird.
Everybody else was just like,
all right,
you're,
you're following the cattle right over the fucking cliff to school.
Two years of language.
Get into college,
pick a major,
decide what the fuck you want to do at 18 and then it,
yeah,
it was one of those things.
And,
um,
I remember when I was 15,
there was like this like woman that came to the school that was supposedly like
a career counselor and she came up with this huge book that looked like yellow
pages or something.
Right?
And everyone had to have an appointment and,
and you'd go in and she'd be like,
okay,
so now what do you want to do?
And like someone to be like,
I want to be a
[inaudible],
open up the book.
And she looked on the doctor and so I walked in,
she's like,
so what do you want to do?
I'm like,
that would be a musician.
And she's like,
sorry,
there's no musician here.
What else would you like to do?
I just walked out.
Oh,
you walked down.
What does she do?
I don't know.
That was it.
I would have,
yeah.
I want to have like an epiphany being like,
wow,
I made,
how many of these fucking kids wanted to do something that's not in this book,
right?
Yeah.
But then you have to look at her.
It's just like there's no way that was her dream in life.
To have a yellow book and talk to people half your age.
What do you want to do?
I want to be a zookeeper.
All right,
let's get to the disease.
All right.
Do you have any khaki shorts?
So you literally have somebody who didn't follow a dream talking you out of
yours and you had the strength to fucking walk away from that.
That's very,
very commendable.
So that's the,
those are the
moments in life there to haunt me that I think that into my life when somebody
said something negative and thank God,
you know,
I,
I didn't latch onto a totally and somebody else like,
cause I have like,
I have like this like three Mike moments in my life,
you know,
like climbing up a fucking cliff that if I went to go this way I would have fell
back down and,
and just the luck of it sometimes when I think of it like,
God,
what if I didn't meet this person?
You know,
and why?
Reading my,
I worked with this guy in a warehouse and I finally found somebody that was into
comedy the way I was and he understood that you could become it.
You know what I mean?
Like he was going like,
dude,
these guys on TV and not funny man,
one of these days I'm going to take a shot of Jack Daniels and just go on stage
and do it.
And all of a sudden like,
cause it just,
you know,
it was on TV that was like a million miles away.
There was no fucking internet or anything.
And uh,
we had,
nobody had video cameras,
nothing.
So it just seemed impossible to me.
It was so impossible.
It didn't even seem impossible.
Didn't even,
I didn't even enter my brain be like fucking going to the moon and all of a
sudden he was just next to me going,
I'm going to fucking do it.
I was just thinking like,
well shit,
if he can try it,
I'm going to try it.
So,
uh,
if I don't run into him and if he doesn't have the balls to Sam,
I'm going to try it.
Then I'm just fucking hanging out with other knuckleheads like me drinking then,
then all of a sudden I'm 30 and where the fuck am I?
You know?
So
do you believe like in like a destiny,
like do you believe that if that wouldn't have happened,
something else would have happened?
Or do you
believe like,
I don't believe in destiny because of tragedy,
right?
I don't think that anybody's destiny is there.
The Hey,
thank God you're not this person.
I just think you get lucky.
You get lucky.
It's,
it's like a half court shot,
I would say in a lot of weight.
Well,
maybe it's not that it's,
it's don't you think it's like partly luck and partly manifestation.
Like if you really want something,
you're going to create the path forward and it can,
and it can go in many directions.
Yeah.
But I also feel like,
and there's also tragedy,
which is unavoidable and,
um,
unpredictable.
The tragedy of where you're born,
right?
What you'll look like,
what race you are.
We're part of the world.
You're in.
Like how lucky I was to be a white guy born in USA,
you know what I mean?
And,
and how lucky I was to be born outside of Boston and had this crazy,
insane seeing this like a lot of like,
you know,
hurdles that were like this big for.
And even then,
even then,
because of all the bullshit,
uh,
that even just,
even if you get that much of a head start,
all of this other shit that can emotionally fuck you up can,
um,
you know,
I mean,
I think by the time I was like nine,
uh,
I,
I had already just sort of like,
I had that,
yeah,
I don't give a fuck.
I don't,
yeah,
I just didn't give a shit like,
and,
but,
but I did,
you know what I mean?
And then that's all your work to get back to that person who did care and did
want stuff.
You just,
as a defense mechanism,
you just like,
yeah,
I don't give a fuck.
Oh,
really?
Is that going to happen?
No.
And then then when that's supposed to,
what make me cry.
Fuck you.
Like I,
I became that person,
which is,
uh,
it's,
it works as far as to get through that shit.
But as far as getting anything that you fucking want in life,
we have to be open and warm and attract stuff to you that you want and you're
over there with you.
Oh yeah.
I don't give a fuck.
Fuck you really,
400 pounds and my chest put 500.
I don't give a fuck to in that dumb guy.
Shit.
Um,
yeah,
there's like,
it's just,
yeah,
that's the,
that's the thing when you're sitting there and at fucking Boston Garden going,
how to fuck if I didn't meet this guy,
if that guy didn't say that,
if I went out that night and went with those people and did that,
you just think of all of that fucking what if shit.
And there's somebody who went out that night and went with those people and then
the fucking sitting in a cubicle or a jail cell or in a fucking loveless
marriage or something.
And then just like why the f that that's somebody's destiny to be in a loveless
marriage?
Is that like I just,
I don't,
um,
yeah,
and Karmas and other one I don't buy into,
I think calmer works.
If you,
if you,
if you believe in it,
what do you,
how do you define Karma?
That basically if you're a good person,
good things happen to you,
but if you're a bad person,
that's not what comment is though.
But in my world it is,
but common,
just like if you like,
comment simply means cause and effect.
So,
okay,
well if you do good things then no,
it's not a bad,
good or bad.
It's just you feel like I'm in school again.
No,
no,
but you do it.
You do.
Can you just give me the F fund?
Although summer school this f
not like you,
you,
you do an action and it causes a result.
Right?
It's as simple as that.
That's all Karma means.
That's like being a safeness.
People thinks that you believe in the devil and people were just like,
ah,
satanism or whatever.
They don't even believe in a heaven or hell or a devil,
but it's just they just living for themselves and everybody's like,
oh,
they were into the devil.
So I was so calm.
I was like,
if you're a fucking nurse or the bad should help us here.
And then in my much business I'd watched these fucking people stealing and doing
all this shit and just look at them and be like,
well,
you know,
nothing's bad is happening to them and I've done a bunch of bad shit and like
overall my life is good.
But I,
you know,
I've heard a lot of people and shit so and so what is it that it just,
it just simply means that you do an action and it creates a result.
So all these people are using that term incorrectly.
Yes.
I just put it in a script incorrectly.
Well for sold eight F F is for family.
Well,
it's correct in that because a lot of people think that that's what it,
what it is.
But like when you go to the root of what Karma is,
it just simply means like you do an action and it's cause and effect.
I saw somebody,
uh,
somebody I follow on Instagram,
they had a picture of a boomerang and it said Karma on it.
So that's actually wrong.
Oh my God,
I wish I knew the real definition than I could have been that pompous ass on the
Internet feeding like actually none of you guys,
that's like one time I saw this guy talking about how he didn't have white
privilege and his idea that he didn't have white privileges because he wasn't
born rich and he had to work for the things that he had.
So his idea is that white privilege is means you're born on a yacht and all of
this fucking shit.
It's like,
no,
that's not what that means.
That means that no point where you with because of your seat and just get pulled
over for being white,
get the shit kicked out of you,
you know,
and all,
all of these other things that would have happened to you.
You just,
you basically because you had to work for things,
you feel you're not privileged.
So literally his definition was privileged.
I always,
I can't give you any more details of it,
I'll tell you afterwards because it's,
how do you deal with like,
um,
Internet trolley type people?
Like,
have you ever struggled with that or wanted to interact with people like that?
Early on I did,
but now it has nothing to do with me.
Yeah.
It has nothing to do.
The amount of shit that I hate that really just has to do with me and my day.
Right.
That I do.
And I let people do that too.
I don't think,
um,
you know any different than they are.
But like,
um,
yeah,
I don't give a fuck.
I don't know.
It'd have to be a specific thing that I did and I thought it was bad too.
And then everybody said you shouldn't have done that,
blah,
blah.
I don't know if I,
I dunno what I,
but if it's just like a,
you know,
so much of whatever you post isn't about what you posted.
It's about what's in the background.
Wait,
so you gotta be so you could do some gravy.
Oh my God,
that's fucking great.
But what's up with that fucking picture on the wall?
Laughing my ass off.
Like that's like,
but what I learned after a while,
it's like that's their moment right on the thread,
right?
Like I'm going to be the guy that notices the thing that starts and then
everybody's talking about what I wanted to talk about.
And then it's this weird thing where you feel good,
but like I,
I,
I do the same thing.
If I send out a tweet and it gets a bunch of retweets and likes,
I'm like,
all right,
people thought that was funny.
So I'm just on the other end of it.
So I just learned like I can't get upset that somebody is noticing something in
this and now they're doing their little show.
Like who the fuck am I?
It's like,
you don't want someone to do that.
Don't post something on there.
And I just look at like,
listen,
you don't want people saying a bunch of bad shit about you.
Don't put your face on the Internet.
It's like you're literally asking for it.
You're sticking your chin out.
Yeah.
And they're winding up and punching you and then you're acting like a victim.
It's like,
well you fucking don't post shit.
Just sit there like this or you know,
post it,
take a few shots and uh,
continue on.
I guess
as a musician like I'm a little firstly like as an instrumental musician,
there's nothing anybody can say about like what I'm saying,
I'm not expressing an opinion,
I'm just playing.
No.
Right.
But then now I've just put out an album of songs with lyrics and there's only
been out there for a right know.
What I'm saying is that in the context of the song,
and I'm very much expressing like stories that are personal but like to go out
there as a comedian and like express really strong opinions.
Like I can't imagine like the difference in like the kind of feedback that you
get.
And
I guess I'm curious what people do is you have to understand that what they do
is they don't,
like I've always said,
he's like,
you can do 80 jokes in a row and someone will sit there laughing and enjoying
your set,
and then the 81st one has to do something about them.
If it's a fat joke in their fat,
if it's about women and they are a woman or it's about this state and there from
there,
and then all of a sudden,
yeah,
it's funny you say that,
then they go,
that statement you made about Arkansas and it's just like,
no,
no.
They were all so they all,
all jokes except for the one.
Right.
You know what I mean?
So there's this,
this,
that,
um,
you know,
there's just that,
that thing,
I just,
I don't pay it any mind.
And um,
yeah,
yeah.
If there was ever any sort of big dust up about something,
I said,
if I actually looked at it and thought I said something wrong,
I'd be like,
alright,
well maybe I'll phrase it a different way.
But like I,
I do think it's absolutely ridiculous that people get offended about a joke that
was told that a show that they weren't at and that was taken so out of context
and no,
you want it to show.
Yeah.
And you chose to click on that thing and the tears.
And another thing too,
if the comedian didn't film it and post it,
if just some fucking asshole in the crowd,
they'd get mad at them.
And it's just like,
well,
what the fuck are you doing if you're this easily offended about standup comedy,
what are you doing watching,
watching standup comedy?
The whole thing is,
so like,
I just saw,
I think it was in Australia,
like the first mammal went extinct due to glue a human global warming and
barely,
barely a word about it.
But like all of this shit,
you know,
fucking,
it's more difficult to be a comedian if you're a woman.
A fucking me too.
Uh,
it's all about us and what we're going through and Llama,
Llama,
blonde,
all of this shit.
And just meanwhile,
all of that pales in comparison to,
you know,
if,
if this fucking places in here,
you're not going to have to worry about any of that.
Right.
That's why I think that the cell phones are super destructive.
Like because they are making everything about me,
me,
look what I'm doing,
look like where I am,
look what I'm eating.
It's,
and,
and were on it constantly.
And it's like,
well the Jesse Chris Delea you follow?
Did you see his thing that he did the uh,
the unfollowing no.
Oh my God.
It's one of my favorite things ever.
He's talking about just making fun of Instagram models.
Uh,
I mean,
I can do it.
I don't feel like I'm doing this joke because he put it out there.
He goes,
look,
he goes,
if you're on Instagram,
it goes in your posts and stuff.
You've just taken a picture of your booty and your titties.
He goes,
make no mistake.
You Hook hooking.
And he just starts calling them hookers and,
and you know,
and then he just starts really like something.
Some of these people I didn't even know fucking exists.
And I guess this is thing that pretty girls still,
when they bite into a sandwich and they kind of look up like that saying like,
yeah,
yeah I'm going to start this thing called the unfollowing.
And what I love about it is first of all I'm seeing him turning the corner as a
comedian because he was always just,
he just had that this guy is a club like a fucking closer,
you know,
and now he's getting,
he's like fine in his like,
like this razor because he was always kind of fun and energetic and stuff and,
but now it's,
it's like,
it's like it's becoming this,
you seeing this force going in this direction.
Like I was fucking cry and laugh for like I'm not afraid to do things along
those lines make me laugh and it's just really fucking was making me laugh.
But the funniest thing about that is that would really bother somebody like
that.
Like cause cause they're living,
not that I would want to hurt those people cause it's very easy to hate
beautiful people.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
it's,
they're very hateable as you're staring at them because you hate yourself.
Like,
why am I this fucking just with like this beauty in all of this stuff.
like,
look at that.
You've got like,
I got to fucking do nine hours of fucking specials to get half as many followers
as you do because you were a fucking half shirt,
you know?
So I just,
there was just something funny,
just finally see a,
a movement to make their numbers go down.
I don't know.
The more I'm saying this out loud,
I'm actually realizing that it's kind of says more about me than about those
people that take those pictures.
But I don't know.
I just thought it was at,
that shit is funny.
So I'm actually watching that girl at the gas station.
I'm going to try to take,
uh,
like this morning I didn't have my phone,
you know,
when I spent the entire,
like two and a half hours ahead with my daughter this morning,
chased her around,
we play with the puzzles,
I read the books.
Uh,
what else did we do was teach her how to play catch and uh,
I think she's going to throw at the left hand,
which would be really cool,
although she's really big.
But the Darryl Dawkins over the top sort of two handed slam,
I know you're not going to know that reference.
He played for the 76 years before you were born.
Um,
so I'm trying to get her not to,
uh,
be into stuff like that.
But the weird thing is,
is because they're so hyper with their energy and all you want to do is just
hold them and hug them.
The best way to do that is if you put on their favorite cartoon and then they
just totally snuggle up next to you,
but then there's no interaction other than the physical because then you just
literally say saying like,
Hey,
hey,
he like,
give me a kiss,
give me kiss.
And they'll go like,
we'll just sort of lean into you and not even look at you,
just give you the chicken.
They just sorta lasered into that.
And I'm like,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I watched a lot of TV.
I did all right in life.
The fuck are you going to do?
So to watch TV and,
and look at your fucking talented you are.
And I'm up there just screaming,
yelling like a lunatic.
Um,
where can people get this album?
anyway.
Yeah.
Listen to music.
Um,
can they download it on iTunes?
Yeah.
Spotify.
I don't think it's true to things going to be said on this podcast than that.
Yeah.
I can't because my fucking computers filled up and I forget my password all the
time.
Well,
I just want to,
uh,
congratulate you because I know you worked so hard on this jet,
just assembling,
abandon,
all of that type of stuff.
Like there's so much more work to this where I just like,
I need to know or to new hour,
I don't have to find a Mike stand guy and all of this shit.
I just have to go out and just go do it.
But,
um,
uh,
whatever you did,
the three songs that I listened to,
I mean,
it is just,
it's on such a high level creativity and everything.
Um,
I'm,
I'm really happy for you and,
uh,
everybody watching listening cause they're always gonna be some clips of this on
video.
Please download and it is called love Romaine.
Love remains.
All right.
Thank you for coming on.
I was going to ask you,
um,
how do you stop doing ums and uhs and you knows and shit like that.
How do I,
yeah,
no I don't.
I do it all the time.
All the time.
Why?
Because I get something that,
cause you do it.
I do it so much.
Oh,
I do it to how you do and you're in care now I didn't know if I don't give a
fuck.
He,
you listen to a
Keith Richards,
ca Jag.
People can't understand him.
He doesn't give a shit.
But like what about when you're doing material?
I guess because you've written the material that's going to be less of that
because you know what you're about to say as opposed to if you're just doing a
podcast.
If I was to actually try to work on something like that,
then I would be up here,
which is not where I want to like yeah,
I want to be,
it's just calming down the rain spout and out my fucking be like considered
technique for a comedian to like at some point work on that.
Yes it would.
Whereas like with like,
um,
I learned,
I started,
uh,
taken from lessons from Dee Dee village,
um,
how many,
like how much you know,
of the way I was playing was getting in the way of me getting to where I wanted
to be with whatever,
because my,
my technique,
I was like sitting like this and I was grabbing the sticks like that was getting
blisters and,
and uh,
like I wasn't making gravity at anything that had to do with physics work for
me.
So I was literally fighting the drum kit and then he taught me all of this
stuff.
I haven't seen him in a couple of months and I'm going back to my bad old
habits.
But,
um,
there is that thing I think that like,
uh,
well we'll say with like a musician,
it's like I don't want to learn how to read man.
I just want to,
you know,
I just want to fucking be this,
free fucking thing.
Right.
And just there is merit in that because you do have those people who only can
play if there's sheet music in front of them,
but if you can somehow marry both of those where you actually have technique but
you can still play from here and not be up there.
I think that that's like the promised land and I always kind of felt is a
comedian.
If you could somehow combine Richard Pryor that's specially did live in concert
on long beach,
if you could combine that with George Carlin,
um,
where his stuff was just like,
I feel like he,
he knew every fucking word that he was going to say and it was like,
yes,
like pop up,
up,
up.
The whole time where prior,
you know,
on that special came walking out,
it was like a hell Gig.
There was people walking around and shit and he just started making fun of
people.
And I think the way he was wired that helped him,
that helped him better than if everyone was just sitting there staring at him
like,
okay,
begin your,
your standup special.
I think that he came out and you know,
sit yo ass down,
you know,
sit,
you'll fucking ugliest out what all that stuff that he was saying.
And everyone was just walking around and he's riffing and then he just just got
in a zone.
And
what's amazing is you begin to his own,
usually that lasts for like six minutes because what happens up to six minutes
of that is you're like,
you start worrying going,
well what happens when this ends and I have to go into my act,
I'm going to be fucked.
And you,
you can't think that because it's almost like when you haven't tried like
meditating.
Yeah.
So you know like when you start to feel like you're floating and like leaving
your body,
if you start thinking,
oh my God,
this is great,
I'm leaving.
And then you'll wash and just go right back down.
So that's the same way with like,
like catching his own.
So like what I've learned a little,
I know about technique with like drums,
he should just practice a little bit every day and then when it starts to become
this thing you don't have to think about then all those skills you learned about
sort of leaving your body and just like,
just like,
I mean your body's there,
but you're,
you're listening to what you're playing that's making you do that next thing.
If you can exist,
you can go back there with all this technique now he not going to get hurt,
you're not going to get tired.
Um,
Emmy eventually will.
But like,
um,
so I think what the comedian,
if,
if I was to try to do that,
like,
okay,
maybe I won't curse as much or something like that.
Like I,
that would definitely be a few steps backwards.
Um,
by that man,
maybe it would help me.
I don't know.
I don't,
I honestly don't think,
I don't think.
Okay.
Cause if I go up there and I start doing that,
it's all about not being here.
Um,
I mean I sell it.
I'm obviously thinking like,
okay,
I'm going to,
it's more like,
okay,
you
like I just walk out,
I just start talking.
And then this Joe comes out and then I said this joke,
which made me think,
oh yeah,
I have this joke and look at this fucking guy.
And then it just sorta just,
oh now we're over here and just you just,
but do you have like a set list of jokes?
Like you want to do it in this order or this order?
Yeah,
but that is all out the fucking window.
The second I go up there and sell,
some nights it goes like that.
And then other nights,
like I definitely have like sections,
but this,
some nights I just go out there and all of a sudden I tell the last choke first
and I'm switching everything around.
And then the guy I told her with is this like,
you know,
waiting to go on stage going like,
dude,
I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
Oh,
you did,
you close a bit in the middle.
I was like,
wait,
he's only doing 35 minutes.
And then you went on,
you did like another,
you know,
whatever,
another 25 after that or something.
Um,
I have like the main set list,
you know,
so that's the,
this is the plan,
the general fucking plan.
And then you go out there and shit happens.
You're in a weird mood.
Somebody says something is you look at something in the back of the room that
makes you think of something and then it go,
it goes in that direction.
And um,
and I am a full believer of doing that because then it doesn't become this grind
cause I used to,
I used to have,
I start with this and then that leads to this and I have my segways and blah
blah blah blah blah.
And it just became like,
you know,
it's rigid.
Yeah.
And then I would be on stage and my mouth would be talking and I would find
myself thinking about going like,
well the second show if the or lets me not close it out,
I could probably be home by,
and then I was just saying yeah.
And then I was just like,
wait,
I'm talking right now.
And people laughing and I'm thinking about other shit.
What the fuck am I doing right now?
And um,
I it,
uh,
it's weird.
I learned how to free myself up through y more through watching musicians.
I've always equated it to music because that's something that I,
I sort of started with.
So I always thought,
I remember talking to a long time ago,
late great Patrice O'Neil.
And I said,
I was telling him,
I was like,
you know,
I always wished I could see somebody cause I,
you couldn't gauge how good you were.
You know,
you can't see how good you are or how much you're improving because you're,
you,
you know what I mean?
You're just in there.
So I always said,
I always wanted this.
I wish I could just have somebody sit down and play guitar at the level of comic
that I am right now.
It's like,
could they change chords?
Could they play without looking?
Could they solo?
Like where am I on that trajectory?
And it's one of the few times he didn't give me any shit.
He was just like,
hi.
He goes,
that's actually interesting.
Then probably I reacted to that and then he probably trashed me cause he
actually opened up for half a second.
So yeah.
Fascinating.
Fascinating nuts and bolts of how to tell Dick and shit.
Jokes will continue after these messages from stamps.com
all right.
Oh baby boot boat me on days beyond Ds.
All red faces in fucking Iceland.
Doodoo Doodoo me on days be on days.
He's eating fucking frozen bison and he's not going to pee his underwears cause
they made out of soft Mick a modal modal.
So who fucking cares me undies?
There are two types of dudes in the world.
Those that go through the gate and those that go over the fence.
Well after years of research and countless experiments with seasoned underwear
scientists,
Mandy's now has an option for both with their new boxer briefs with the fly.
It took a while,
but now men on both sides of the aisle enjoy the world's softest undies.
Not only will you feel like your loins are being hugged by joy itself,
but me undies gives you multiple style options for men and women men can wear.
Can now try the new boxer brief with a fly.
It's the same.
Great.
Cut His boxer briefs just a whole.
Now for number one.
Okay.
Meanders is also the Goto for the softest long where on the planet hang out and
they're Super Cup.
Well,
you're going to hang out with that hole in your underwears hang out in.
They're super comfy lounge pants in onesies.
Yes,
Beyonce's makes one season there.
Incredibles,
a Incredibles like the movie Mian Ds has a great offer for my listeners.
At any first,
for any first time purchasers,
you can get 50% off and free shipping.
Get 15% off a prayer.
The most comfortable undies you will ever put on to get your 15% off your first
pair,
free shipping,
and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
You go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr that's me,
undies.com/burr.
All right,
legal zoom.
Everybody is zooming in a legal way there.
A running a small business has a lot of work.
I am so tired of running my small business.
It takes time and money and you want all the time and money you have to go
towards growing your business.
But what happens when legal zoom hurdles wet?
What happens when legal hurdles pop up along the way?
Legal Zoom is there to help.
Nearly 2 million Americans have used legal zoom to stat their businesses with
LLCs and corporations in more.
Uh,
but even after your business is set up,
legal zoom can still help out things like lease agreements,
changing tax laws and contract reviews,
all part of running your own business.
Uh,
and these are precisely the kinds of constantly hurdles that can take time away
from your growing business.
That's why legal zoom created their business legal plan.
Get advice for running your business from vetted independent attorneys and tax
professionals available in all 50 states.
The best part is you won't get charged by the hour.
Since legalzoom is not a law firm,
make your time and money work for you.
A check out legal zooms business legal planet legal zoom.com now and enters a
and get special savings when you enter [inaudible] at checkout B,
you are legal zoom where life meets legal legal zoom.com.
Okay,
next.
What do we got here?
Alright,
butcher box dude,
butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage breed pork.
My favorite,
the incredible quality and portrait box means a meet start with an with the
commitment to raise animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones before
they're slaughtered.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals or if he got giantism it's probably
a slider.
You can choose from.
Five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork ladies,
mixed box custom box.
Let you choose your own cuts like a real American.
My favorite is,
uh,
the heritage breed pork,
the butcher box difference.
A butcher box,
meats come from humanely raised open pasture.
Animals that frolic and are never fed antibiotics,
hormones or fatty livers.
They listened to cat,
the captain and Tenille before getting whacked.
Get the ultimate breakfast bundle.
That's two packages of Bacon and two pounds of breakfasts.
Soffit sausage for free.
And your first box plus $20 off your first box.
Go to butcher box.com/burr or enter
the Promo Code Burr.
Last but not least,
dollar shave club.
Ah,
you'll have this smooth as balls on the blog.
Darla,
she dollar Shave Club has everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
And you never have to go to a store.
That's because they deliver everything you need to your door and they keep you
fully stocked and what you use so you don't run out.
Here's outworks dollar shave club has everything you need to get ready.
No matter what you're getting ready for.
They have you cut.
They have you covered.
Head to toe for your hair,
your skin,
your face,
you name it,
they have it.
And they have this new program where they automatically keep you stocked up on
the products you use.
You determine what you want and when you want it.
And it shows up right at Dilla from a once a month to once every six months.
Plus they're handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save it.
Right now,
dollar shave club has a bunch of status sets you can try for just five bucks,
like their oral care kit.
Jesus,
he had a rough weekend,
didn't you sweetheart?
All right.
After that,
after that,
the,
the uh,
the restock box ships regular sized products at regular prices,
uh,
at the regular price get stat,
you started set for just $5 right now@dollarshaveclub.com slash [inaudible]
that's dollar shave club.com/burr and now for bill burst theme song.
Oh,
I get a theme song out of this.
I would've thought it would've been on like a Ukulele,
some sort of Irish Jig song.
Do they play Ukuleles out there?
I don't know.
You have to play though.
Seriously?
I have to play.
Yeah.
Why do I have to pick?
I'm going to sing the theme song.
Well,
then you have to tell a joke.
I have to tell a joke or why do I have to do my hobby?
Oh,
do you know what I mean?
What am I playing
Dan
to crack?
I don't have any of your close.
My ears are fucking junk.
Okay.
Is it?
And play it really softly.
Is that piano or 14 can you just make sure you do the retard,
Huh?
The retard.
Yeah.
I learned.
How were you going to retard in the end?
All right.
You Ready?
Yeah.
All right.
Bye Bye
now.
Bow Burst Monday morning podcast.
That's how it has to,
and that's the retard.
All right.
[inaudible] almost die.
Go.
So Jerry
to
cod
and no,
he's five [inaudible] four
[inaudible]
the
hey,
what's going on?
It's built bird.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 25th,
2011.
How the fuck are you?
Yeah.
Well that's good.
Uh,
I'm in a good mood here.
I just did the levels this week.
Let me know how you guys have,
uh,
if this is too loud because some truckers,
some truckers,
some truckers wrote me in,
hey man,
I'm driving across this fucking country.
Bring in Bacon and beard.
All these fat fucks out here.
And when my,
when my,
when my roommate gets a rumbling,
I can't hear your podcast.
They are,
come on.
Good Buddy.
Can you turn it up for me?
You've got your ears on what?
That whole fucking phenomenon back in the 70s,
you guys old enough to remember that Shit when having a CB and being a fucking
redneck trucker was actually in for half a second.
And I'm not talking about that Ashton Kutcher horse shit when he walked around
with this fucking greasy trucker hat right before he started banging that
fucking hot mom up there in Wyoming with their big fake fucking tits.
I'm not talking about that.
His trucker hat that actually said von Dutch on it.
Did you guys even know what the fuck that was?
I didn't tell him.
Moved out to La and realized that that was the guy who did all the custom paint
on the hot rods.
Isn't that what the fuck it was I'm talking about before that talking about
when,
when there was shows on TV with guys who hung out with monkeys and it was Clint
Eastwood was making movies with monkeys.
Like that was like,
those were like the vampire movies
of the late seventies.
He had any which way but loose any which way you can.
Uh,
why the fuck am I doing a trilogy with an Orangutan,
I think was the last one that he did.
And they even had a TV show.
It's my voice cracks in a TV show called a Bj and the bear.
And the bear was a,
had a hat on like Paul Bear Bryant who was the old coach or the fucking Alabama
Crimson tide.
And I didn't get that,
you know,
cause what,
what,
what were they saying about him?
You know,
they're calling him a monkey.
Is that racist to call a white man a monkey?
Oh Gee.
Sheesh.
Um,
this is the podcast for this week,
ladies and gentlemen.
So this is,
this is going to be the levels.
I adjusted the base.
Somebody said the,
the base was too fucking low.
Like I have all these buttons on these,
on these goddamn thing.
I don't know how to work it.
So I just realized that there's a high,
a mid and a low range.
So gradually,
eventually this podcast will become professional.
Look at me.
I'm pacing around.
I'm pacing around my old fucking bedroom.
That's what I'm doing here on Easter.
Fucking Easter Sunday.
Did you guys,
do you guys go to church?
Holy,
holy,
holy eat far kid
way for,
it's the body of a guy who came out of the womb that was never fucked.
Is that what you guys did?
Did you give you a little colored eggs for the fucking weed smokers?
Man.
MMM MMM.
Fucking tired.
I'm just trying,
I'm trying to go on energy this week.
People,
I just,
that was just,
you know,
I was like,
remember back in the day when you get into a fight with somebody and you knew
you were going to lose.
So you just had that first spastic eight seconds of the fight where you like
woo
just swinging before he just started punching in the head and you started crying
and then the girl you had a crush on,
that's the first person when you looked up,
that's the one you always saw the dirt and the side of your face in the fucking
pebble stuck in your skin and you just,
she just,
you know,
you don't know what kills you is she didn't look away.
She was walking away,
but she was making eye contact and she didn't know what she was thinking because
she was so young.
But it was just,
her inner DNA was clicking in already.
That was just letting her know,
was just giving her innocent little stay away from that.
You know,
when she gets older it gets more sophisticated with,
you cannot breed with that
when you're young.
It's just sort of,
he looks icky.
Um,
anyways,
the fuck was I talking about.
I'm talking about truckers.
Let's,
let's work our way back here.
Bj and Mackay,
B j Mckay Yan,
his best friend bear.
Is there any truckers listen to this shit?
And that's why you became a trucker.
You know,
you'll flunk in math,
you're sucked in English class history didn't interest you.
And then one day there was a show,
they'll let you know that your dream of someday driving a truck with a
chimpanzee could come true.
You're like,
dude,
this is what the fuck I'm gonna do
speaking it did.
Um,
I've mentioned this week that I was going to have a couple of guests on the
Monday morning podcast.
Not One guest that to guests,
but two guests,
sorry.
It's gotta be three,
right?
You always got to say,
not this,
but this.
Which is a hard thing to do when the numbers too,
but I plowed through it.
I'm going to have two guests and um,
I was thinking of doing it on this podcast and I was like,
you know what?
Well,
why don't I do two podcasts this week?
Why don't I overindulge like all the kids running around with their fucking
candy,
not really learning the story of Jesus is in this store.
This is the day about the conquering of life.
Over death.
Right?
I read a little bit,
everybody was thinking Jesus was dead.
They were like,
I can't believe it.
He was the number one draft pick.
Dude.
We was supposed to get the championship or what does he do?
We fucking shits the bed on Friday.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is he last?
I already was in a cave hiding by a rock.
He's fucking dead.
His career's over.
It's it.
We need them.
We need to go to another motivational speaker.
And then what happens?
All of a sudden,
some nosy prek
walked in,
right?
Started rolling the rock back.
Probably the original Geraldo Rivera.
You know what's,
I'm just fucking amazing.
Medieval mustache.
And he came walking in there and Jesus was just laying there,
right?
If I can overuse this reference for the 500th time and two weeks lay in there
like,
fucking Burt Reynolds got that leaf over his cock.
Why do I talk about that so much?
Do I have a crush on Burt Reynolds?
Odu,
a fucking queer,
uh,
sorry and adjusted like there.
Um,
now it's just fucking,
it's just hilarious to me.
I love the seventies I love what you could get away with,
you know?
So anyways,
so Jesus is laying there right in his playgirl fucking spread his hippie hair
laying down,
you know?
And then,
let me see if I can remember this from church and then these,
like there was like at least three guys came walking in and they were the guys
who hung out with him and his last supper right before Judas betrayed him.
Do you know Jesus?
Nah,
dude,
I don't know that motherfucker.
What do you think he's going to say?
You just nailed them to a fucking piece of wood.
Give a fuck who it is up on that.
I don't know that guy.
Yeah.
Good for you.
Where'd it go?
Jesus.
Let's get the fuck Outta here.
I really think,
I think Judas gets a bad rep.
Look,
I think you should always stick by your friends.
But Jesus Christ,
what the fuck he supposed to do?
And then it's over.
You know?
Do you realize the nerve damage you're going to get if somebody drives the
nails?
And I've heard different things through the hands of,
through the forearms.
You know,
ran between the radius and Ulna,
the fucking nerve damage you're going to get at that point,
right?
That you're not,
you're not coming back from that.
He can't continue being a carpenter.
But wait a minute,
he says,
son of God,
why didn't he just,
just,
you know,
hover off that thing and may in just go heal and then he was better.
Why didn't he do that?
You know why I didn't do that?
Because then he couldn't guilt shift for your entire life.
Look at me.
Look what I did.
Happy Easter.
Everybody.
So anyways,
they fucking,
uh,
so yes.
So the guy dies,
right?
He dies and uh,
everybody's like,
Oh God,
what do we do?
Then it started raining really bad and then Steve Carell put a bunch of animals
on a boat,
right?
He saved them.
No wait.
Then those three guys would find them in the cave would have been dead because
they weren't on the boat.
All right,
let's back up.
Let's back up to 12 a s that no bs before Steve,
before Steve Carell.
Beast BSC.
Alright,
what the fuck am I?
Three fucking guys walk into the damn cave and then they go a,
Hey,
are you sleeping?
Are you awake?
And Jesus,
Nah,
I'm up.
Yeah.
Like you're not Jesus.
We saw you.
You died.
And I go,
it is me.
And then,
and then they didn't believe it was him and then they were in trouble,
you know?
Then they would sit next to Judas at the fucking bench,
outside the principal's office,
waiting to go in and see,
God.
Why did you say he didn't know my son?
You know,
my son.
You've been over my house.
What is your story?
Judas,
why did you deny him?
Hey listen man,
you know,
I didn't want any trouble.
The guy was,
you know,
I was coming to get you that,
that you know,
Judas is basically that fucking guy.
Yeah.
It was at Bobby and Saturday night fever.
Remember that shit when he drove away and he didn't fight.
That's who Judases.
Um,
is he built?
Yeah,
I think he is.
According to my version,
my new version of,
of the Old Testament.
Is this the Old Testament or the new?
The new one,
whatever.
So these fucking guys walk in and then,
uh,
basically how they figure out it's Jesus is he takes one of their hands and he
puts it into the wound on the side of him and then they go,
oh yeah,
it is you.
It was weird because I hung out with you and I know what your face looks like,
but unless I stuck my hand inside your fucking chest cavity,
I wasn't really convinced.
Wait a minute.
Yeah.
Feel that liver.
Tell me that's not Jesus.
That's him.
That's fucking him.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's the history of our,
the Jesus part of it.
Through it.
It is hot as fuck in this room.
I'm in my old department.
I have to have the doors closed.
Oh,
so anyways,
yeah.
So I decided I was going to do two podcasts this week.
I'm going to do the regular one,
the regular one where I ramble and I piss off fucking Jesus freaks and talk to
truckers,
talking to truckers.
What do you guys do on your trucks?
You got the confederate flags,
Diego Ye high.
When you change lanes and you know,
you're like,
you're like one point when liberals do shit like that.
That's one thing I've noticed about liberals there as fucked up to the left as
the people all the way on the right,
you know,
there is intolerant and all.
Am I preaching Jesus?
It's hot in here.
This isn't me.
I don't preach,
do I Dow?
Um,
I'm just trying to get my bearings here.
People the fuck was I talking?
Oh,
and then he got the Easter bunny.
All right.
And according to Wikipedia,
the Easter bunny came from Germany,
you know,
so all you people out there think Germans are the most evil motherfuckers on the
planet.
Just cause they started two world wars and tried to wipe an entire group of
people off the face of the earth by sticking them in ovens,
you know?
Yeah.
All right,
you got him there.
A little evil there,
but you know what?
They got a soft side.
They got his soft side and his name is Peter Cottontail,
right?
Here comes Peter cottontail,
up and down the bunny trail,
hip.
Any happen?
He fuck you,
motherfucker.
Right?
One of the few Easter songs I ever knew.
He's got jelly beans for Bobby colored eggs for six
pursue.
Um,
so anyways,
I guess they brought that tradition over here and people have asked the
Seinfeldian question,
why do they have earnings coming into the room?
Because evidently,
uh,
there was a sign of fertility,
I guess according to Wikipedia,
basically birds,
you know,
they lay a bunch of eggs very fertile and bunny rabbits when they,
uh,
when they get fucking knocked up,
right?
When some fucking hair starts pulling the back of their ears as he's fucking
Jack Hammering in the back of that little rabbit pussy,
what comes out,
right?
Like fucking 48 Ravitz every God damn time.
That's why snakes is so fat that just,
that just not the,
this,
there's just plenty of rabbits to f to feast on.
Right.
I don't fucking know people,
I glance at this shit right before I started the podcast.
So basically
they combine the two of those.
I don't know why.
The whole fucking thing is weird and it has to do
with life,
I guess.
And Jesus coming back from the dead,
coming back to life and the eggs.
The latter fucking though it makes no goddamn sense to me.
I mean,
you know what it is.
I think the story of those guys walking into the cave and somebody getting
nailed to a goddamn cross and then somebody having to stick their hand in the
side of a human being like they're reaching into a giant wallet was just too
crazy.
It
was just too creepy to say to kids,
so you got to come up with this shit,
right?
You know it was pre TV.
What do you do?
Just give him a basket full of fucking colored eggs and some candy.
Do you know when I was a kid,
I thought those Cadbury eggs were chocolate fucking eggs.
Remember that commercial buck,
buck,
buck.
Remember that in the fucking rabbit was sitting there.
I thought that the,
and I thought they were disgusting and I have a sweet tooth and I never got them
because when they broke them open,
it looked like a fucking egg yolk inside of it.
And I was like,
there's no way that that's,
I don't want to chocolate covered egg.
Oh,
hi Luna.
[inaudible] let's get on with the podcast for this week.
I have a couple of announcements.
So what I was,
what I was trying to say,
I don't even know if I've said at this point,
this is why I never do podcasts when I travel,
but I had,
I had a quick trip came in from Detroit.
Um,
so rather than just do the one podcast and have Bobby,
Bobby,
Bobby Kelly,
my old roommate,
we're going to tell stories about how we used to live together and we almost
beat the shit out of each other.
And that time he threw the racket ball when I had the Conan O'brien audition and
it record shade off the wall,
went into the bathroom and hit me in the mouth and cut my fucking lip right
before I had to go down and showcase for the Conan people as he was riding on
this bootleg stair master that he fucking took off the sidewalk because he grew
up in a fucking junk yard.
All right.
That's one of the stories.
Will be telling.
And then we're also going to be lucky enough to have the teen idols sensation
from the opiate Anthony Program.
Joe De Rosa,
everybody,
Joe de Roses,
also going to be on the Monday morning podcast,
this special edition,
the limit,
the Shelby gt 500 edition of this mother fucking podcast.
Um,
Oh,
speaking of which,
uh,
last week,
we added a donation button,
bunch of people donated.
I really appreciate it.
You know,
I'm able to fucking pay my web guy few more fucking dollars.
And,
uh,
eventually,
you know,
I'm going to be able to hire somebody to help me with this mixer.
So it sounds okay.
I'm going to have a whole little fucking radio station.
I'm taking this thing to the next level people,
uh,
but some of you guys were actually having difficulty finding the,
the podcast donation button.
If you just go on the mmp.com the official fan page of the Monday morning
podcast.
If you just go on there,
um,
if you look under the icons on the right,
you'll see the Twitter,
Facebook a and something else over there.
Those icons,
you know,
right underneath that you'll see donate and there's a big donate button.
You just click on that and whatever you want to give people been given like 10,
20 bucks.
The average has been about 20 bucks.
I've had a couple of ridiculous,
uh,
donations from people and,
um,
I tried to write back as many as you can as I could to say thanks.
I'm going to write back some more today after I do this.
I really appreciate you guys kicking in and all the,
uh,
positive feedback I got.
I really appreciate you guys kicking in for this thing.
Um,
and I'm going to take the money and reinvest into this fucking thing and I
realized I got myself a little radio show here.
I'm kind of excited.
I'm kind of excited about this and I want to take it to another level.
Um,
and speaking of another level,
um,
the Tribeca film festival has begun and cheat the film that we did.
Um,
our film cheat as I should say,
uh,
debuted last night and uh,
they put us on at the end of eight different films and evidently I wasn't there.
Joe De Rosa fresh off his fucking cover shoot of teen beat magazine,
uh,
was there.
And once he got done signing autographs for all the kids,
he went in and evidently according to him I got a text,
he said,
the film fucking killed.
Uh,
I don't,
I can't even tell you the last time I was at excited,
I was like really nervous.
Um,
and I got to give him Kudos because I wouldn't have the balls to sit there.
And just the,
the unbelievable lack of power that you'd have in that situation.
As a comedian,
I'm standing,
it's live.
If it's not funny,
I can do something about it in the moment.
Even if I'm doing like the podcast,
I can feel when it's not funny,
I'll make,
I'll can do something,
but film is done and you just sit in there and if it's not working,
you can't stop it.
You can't Improv,
you can't feed the crowds.
You just sit in there.
It's done.
Um,
but evidently he sat there and a,
I guess it fucking killed and uh,
we're hoping all the other screens are going to go that way.
Pretty much all the shows are sold out.
So I want to thank everybody once again,
it's a big love fest here.
I want to thank everybody for uh,
for coming out and support in the film.
I hope you guys enjoyed those of you get tickets,
those who,
who aren't going to be able to see it.
We will definitely figure out a way to get it out there to you guys so you will
be able to see it.
And uh,
and with that you want to get something to so much of a maniac sports fan.
I am though.
However,
despite the fact that I got offstage,
sold out show at the Royal Oak Theater,
Royal Oak,
Michigan,
want to thank everyone who came out for that fucking thing.
I get off stage.
All right.
And I am well aware that the Bruins and the Canadians are in double overtime.
Now last week,
you remember the Bruins lost the first two.
All the Montreal fans are walking away from their NP fucking three players right
now,
aren't you?
Where way you going?
Come back.
Sit down.
Sit down and take it a little bit.
All right.
You mother fuckers.
You sent me a lot.
He is snooty little French Canadian fucking emails talking about how Boston
Bruins were done because we lost the first two are at home.
Didn't you?
Did look at me.
Come on Jack up here.
I'm up here.
Yeah,
you sent me a bunch of fucking emails saying that we were finished.
All right,
and what did I say?
I said last week.
Ask Not know.
I said last week that we weren't finished and I said that we were going to
fucking kill them and game three we didn't kill him,
but we beat them.
All right.
For those of you aren't hockey fans,
we beat them in their fucking building.
They could have gone up three Oh now it's two one.
Oh no big deal.
Just win game four.
They're up three one they got another home game.
No Way.
The Bruins are gonna win again.
It in their fucking building.
This is the fucking
Montreal Canadians,
right.
I saw a video on youtube that was hyping this series and when the,
all they showed was the Canadians kicking the shit out of the Bruins.
Even like modern day footage.
Then winning fights,
everything in the,
in the,
the narrator goes to to close it out and said pretty much owned the Bruins
forever.
Right
now and did that get my blood going?
It's like they haven't owned the Bruins since pre 1988 okay.
Up to 90 87 they fucking owned our asses.
We couldn't beat them,
but since then they've been a nonfactor.
We've met them 10 times in the playoffs.
We've beaten him six times.
The last time we played them,
we beat them four games in a fucking row,
the last two in their building.
I don't get it.
They're not in the way of us or anybody else winning a cup then not who they
used to be.
They dominated a 16 league that it's,
that's it.
It's over.
And then the hangover of the expansion six until everybody got on their fucking
feet and then the added the Edmonton Oilers and the 70s were over.
They haven't dominated sense.
All right.
Enough already with that bullshit.
So anyways,
all they gotta do is win game four.
What happens to fucking Bruins when it,
and over time,
now it's two,
two,
but going back to Boston,
right last night,
double over time,
fucking game.
I'm on stage missing every fucking second of it.
Having the time of my life though,
having a great time.
All these people showed up in fucking Detroit,
absolutely beautiful fucking town that just needs a coat of paint and evidently
some windows and then you really need to like Detroit looks like a hurricane
came and everybody boarded up there fucking windows and they never bothered to
take it off.
That's what it really looks like.
It's sad because they have these beautiful brick houses.
There's a few cities that I go to and it makes me sad how beautiful they are.
And they've just been run down Detroit,
Cleveland,
um,
upper Darby when I went there and,
uh,
last couple of weeks ago did tower theater and affiliates just,
it's just,
it's awful.
It's like you're looking at like 200 seasons of this old house.
You could just have a never ending of people coming in and fixing up these
awesome houses and making them great again.
But anyways,
so I get off stage.
This is how much of a fucking psycho sports fan am.
I know that the,
uh,
our film is debuting at the Tribeca film festival.
This is the first film I've ever done.
Like this where I was involved at this level.
Okay.
And I opened,
I look at my phone and I get a text from Joe Derosa,
right?
And it says,
ah,
okay.
The,
the film fucking killed with like 20 exclamation points behind it.
So I'm totally psyched.
Now once you think that,
that would be my first phone call to find it at.
Now,
the first thing I'm doing is I'm looking for texts from fellow Bruins fans and
I'm not getting anything that's let me know what happened.
I got a couple of texts saying,
can you fucking believe this?
Cause it was this unbelievable game
and uh,
but nothing saying whether they want a loss.
And My fucking heart sunk in.
It reminded me of the time I was watching working the Improv in DC and the
fucking patriots were playing the Colts in the AFC championship game and we were
up like 20 to nothing or something,
right?
The half.
And uh,
I've got a bunch of calls from pats fans,
gonna Peyton Manning's choking again,
can you fucking believe this?
And when all these pats fans were already calling me,
and when I got off stage,
when the show was over,
90 fucking minutes later after I sold DVDs,
probably about two hours later I got off and I had no text and no messages and I
was like,
oh,
called up,
found out the fucking colts actually came back to win.
So I get off stage and all I have is people reacting to the overtime.
And then I don't get any
fucking texts.
So I assumed the worst that the Canadians won.
And I called up a somebody.
I said,
what happened?
Eyes fucking squinting.
Cop made this call before I found out about the film and what did I find out?
What did I find out the fucking Bruins wanted?
Now we're up three games to two.
Okay?
Against this team that's pretty much owned as forever.
Give me a fucking break.
You guys owned us and I fucking own the fact that you owned us,
but you have not owned us since 1988 you have not stand the fuck down.
It's been a whole different era since then.
Enough already.
How far?
You know what it is?
It's just lazy sports journalism.
You just Dustin off that same fucking stupid story enough already.
You ought to be ashamed of yourself.
Whoever wrote that piece.
All right,
two thumbs down from this Bruins fan.
So that's the deal,
dude.
It's fucking three to two and now we're going up to Montreal with once again
with an opportunity to close out this series in fucking Montreal.
And not to mention I also twittered.
I don't tweet I Twitter.
I said a few days ago,
what did I say?
I'm going to be that guy,
dude.
I called it this week.
I fucking said this game.
The series is going seven and Tim Thomas is going to be the difference.
Carrie prices not there yet.
I'm telling you,
we're going to beat these mother fuckers.
You hear me?
Montreal,
we're going to fucking beat you sons of bitches.
All right,
and then what?
Then what?
Then we're going to be going on 25 years.
A quarter of a century of you guys not own in us.
I you still going to dust that fucking story of it's over.
It's over.
You guys are over and this fucking series is over because we're closing it out
and games.
I'm fucking with you.
You know what I really think's going to happen?
I think.
I don't think that the Montreal fans are going to allow their team to lose this
series in their building.
You know,
this is the one thing I got to give.
I've got to give a couple of things to the fucking Canadians aside from having
one of the best uniforms in sports,
despite the fact that when I look at it,
I,
I it makes me fucking rage.
I gotta admit it's a great fucking uniform.
Number two,
your fans are fucking ridiculous.
They just,
they're just awesome fans.
You're obnoxious,
you're snooty or whatever.
But I mean though,
the way that you guys push your team,
that's why I think you guys are going to win game six because of that shit.
And also,
uh,
I really hope that sue is going to be a fucking free agent and we can sign them.
Cause I think that guy's the shit and he's going to be a star.
Other than that,
go fuck yourselves.
Go eat a fucking croissant or whatever.
Uh,
and get ready to start golfing people because this series is fucking,
oh,
I'm fucking with you.
I never talk shit like this and I'm not confident that it's over.
This thing changed on a dime and it can change back again.
When the fuck am I going to get a job in one of these sports channels and put on
a sport coat and sit there with my little pen,
tapping it,
waiting to chime in as the straight laced guy.
You know,
Yo,
they always got the straight laced guy going up in Montreal,
the Blue Block,
a ruse or above the blah,
blah,
blah.
What are you gonna say about that bill?
And I'm the fucking moron who wears like a short sleeve shirt under a blazer.
Well,
I tell you,
if I'm Karie price,
I gotta be thinking,
okay.
Um,
all right.
I know what people are saying.
Way Too much sports talk.
Well,
why don't you go fucking read a book then.
What do you want me to get back to my,
my amazing,
uh,
talks about history.
I don't know.
Shit.
All right.
You listen to me.
Hear me itching that fucking beard.
All right.
I have another announcement to make this week.
Uh,
Seattle,
the,
uh,
anti social network tour,
the,
uh,
the brilliant comedian,
comedic,
a fucking brainchild,
whatever,
what does that expression,
whatever the,
the,
the lineup.
Goddammit.
I'm trying to hype this.
What is the fucking word?
Uh,
gives a shit.
I'm too stupid.
Look,
Jim Norton came up with this great idea.
He said,
you know what?
I got to show down in Atlantic City,
New Jersey.
I do whatever year.
What if I brought down a couple of pals?
A couple of buddies brought down David.
Tell Jim Breuer and myself,
we had a great time.
People showed up.
We had to add shows.
We like,
Holy Shit.
This could be something.
So now we're adding cities.
Uh,
the next city that we are adding is Seattle.
Um,
I,
uh,
I am officially announcing Seattle a die.
I'm officially announcing it without the fucking date.
Of course.
I am the fucking worst.
I had everything laid out.
There it is.
Here it is.
I got it right now.
I don't.
Here's a new button I hit.
There's the fucking Easter egg.
Shit.
Is this it?
I belly is such a dumb fuck.
Oh,
here we go.
All right.
Uh,
Seattle should be announced on Monday,
April 25th check.
I am doing that.
It goes on sale Friday,
April 29th at www.tickets.com.
The show is on July 1st at the beautiful,
the lovely paramount theater in Seattle,
Washington.
Um,
you can go to antisocial,
comedy.com and facebook.com/antisocial comedy will have direct ticket links in
all other show information.
And a,
I am going to announce it says,
please make sure you announced this first thing Monday.
Well,
I think the Monday morning podcast is the first perfect vehicle.
So there you go.
People,
Seattle,
Washington,
July 1st tickets go on sale next Friday,
April 29th go to tickets.com antisocial comedy.com or facebook.com/antisocial
comedy.
Come on out and check out a three amazing fucking comedians and myself
mopping up,
not even mopping up.
I'm coming out of the gate.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
what was I just going to say about Seattle that I have anything else to hype
about that?
Oh,
I know zen we got,
we got that same tour.
If you like that line up and you live in different parts of the country,
that's a west west coast date.
If you want a Midwest date,
um,
June 15th,
we're at the Chicago Theater in Chicago,
Illinois,
one of the most underrated cities in this goddamn country.
And,
um,
if you live on the east coast,
uh,
May 30th we're going to be at constitution hall in Washington DC.
I can't wait to do that gig because fans of a standup comedy,
I might be a little wrong on a couple of these specials,
but I know Eddie Murphy tape delirious there.
I believe Martin Lawrence taped a special there and Chris rock did.
I don't know which Chris rock one.
So,
uh,
I think it's fitting that four white guys are now going to come in and hold
hands and do one giant show.
All right.
To take that venue back.
No,
I'm kidding.
Um,
the fuck was that all about,
I think that was one for the truckers.
Um,
all right,
let's plow ahead with the podcast here.
People not put the announcements enough with the bullshit.
Uh,
let's get to uh,
AH,
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
why don't I have this fucking laid out?
Oh,
I know.
Last week I asked you guys,
I said,
uh,
can you guys help me out?
You know,
by giving me a little bit of feedback on last week's podcast to help me keep the
fucking ball in the air here for an hour.
And here's something.
Last week we were talking about,
uh,
STDs.
Somebody wrote in and was talking about how they met this wonderful lady.
Okay?
And he goes to the zoo and they're not looking at the ostriches.
Then I looking at the gorillas there,
fucking looking into each other's eyes and they just totally connecting.
You like juggling.
I like juggling,
right?
Totally hit it off.
Then it finds out,
she finds out,
the dude finds out she's got herpes.
What do I do?
Wow.
Let's just remind me that old sesame street song.
No left turn.
No right turn foam.
What do you do?
Remember that one.
Every once in a while and old sesame street song pops into my head.
Um,
and uh,
you know what I was thinking of the one the other day.
Do you remember Bob Soap?
All white man?
You remember him from the,
uh,
from a sesame street?
Bob was one of the widest guys ever,
and they sang a song,
I think it was teaching you about your fucking the shit on your face and
everybody's singing.
I got it.
I got a nose.
I got a mouth.
I got,
I got two years.
I got two eyes.
The singing,
this little ditty.
I remember Susan,
the black girl on there,
right?
She sang about the ears right before Bob and she totally sasses it up,
which made Bob sound even wider.
I forget all the whole song went.
But Susan,
the black chick went first and then Bob,
who made fucking,
uh,
John Denver looked like a fucking,
like,
he was in the,
the Goddamn crips.
So she sings about the ears and then he comes on the Somme basically.
I don't think I remember it.
She goes,
I got to,
is to help me.
And he goes,
I've got
two
[inaudible].
They're both the same size.
Yeah.
And I remember being like five or six years old thinking there was something
wrong with Bob that he shouldn't have sung it that way.
Can anybody send me a link to that?
I've got two [inaudible].
Oh,
Bob,
what happened?
What happened to you?
How did you grow up in the fifties isolated.
Did you have a bomb shelter?
Did you put your fucking white head between your white knees out there in the
White Culdesac?
Is that what happened?
Then you found out you had a love of music but you couldn't sing rock and roll's
.
Everybody called you cool.
Where
and then what happened?
You got into sock puppets and next thing you know you meet a guy named Jim
Henson.
It makes a pass at you,
grabs your ass.
You start just shove your face into his bed.
You guys are making out,
right?
Ugh.
Disgusting.
All right.
Yeah.
Is nobody with the beard safe on this podcast?
First Jesus and now Jim Henson.
Um,
and you know it's funny Jim Henson's bird a bird.
His fucking beard kind of looks like one of those Easter egg basket fucking
things,
right?
You know what?
You guys can go fuck yourself right now.
I know it's off the rails.
I know this whole thing is just gone dead.
Just went down an alley that has no exit.
I mean here sweating.
I shouldn't be sweating while doing this.
You know,
it's funny,
I'm,
I'm in my old bedroom right back in the day when I was a single man,
when I used to bring back the broads.
Okay.
Oh God.
The nightmares I used to be,
you know,
so you don't really fuck me up was Dr Drew,
Dr Drew.
Like if I met doctor drew,
I've done a show a couple of times,
right?
His love line thing,
if I did his show 10 fucking years ago,
I swear to God there,
there's a good eight or nine girls I never would have hooked up with.
Just it's,
it's fucking unreal.
You gotta listen to that guy show.
I realize the reason why I,
okay.
Probably a third of the women that I fucking hooked up was I was damaged and I
was going out hooking up with other damaged people and that was the connection.
And then we had this fucking crazy,
I'm not even going to get into it.
You got to listen to his show.
He's fucking unreal.
They sit there and they see people call in like the girls that have this little
mousy voices,
you know those voices that turn guys on those creepy little voices today?
Yeah.
Um,
me and my boyfriend and he just immediately goes,
what happened to you when you were five?
And you find out they got molested when they were five.
And then there was some sort of fucking like,
I don't know what you call it.
They just stopped growing mentally and they kept talking that way.
I see.
It just fucking blows my mind member.
Back in the day when a girl came up talking like that,
you're like,
this girl's easy,
right?
[inaudible] Baba talking like pebbles on the Goddamn Flintstones.
What happened then?
You dictate.
So here's an easy one to fucking knock out of the park.
I didn't realize it.
I feel like some sort of fucking pervert
Jesus.
That wasn't funny at all.
It wasn't what was on my chest.
I had to get it off.
All right,
so let's plow ahead.
So last week this person was sitting there talking about,
you know,
so he met some lady and she had the fucking,
uh,
you know,
she's got the blisters on a thing there.
Right.
And she of course tells an innocent story of,
it was one guy and he went down on me and he had a cold sore and that was it.
That's when somebody has an STD.
That's always how they tell the story.
They never say,
listen,
I was an absolute fucking whore and I was fucking everything that moved and I
really have no idea when I got it where I got it or who I gave it to.
All I know is I got it.
And if you want some of it,
I got it.
I got it right fucking here.
No one says that man or a woman there was just go,
I was on my way to Bible study and somebody said,
would you like a drink?
I didn't know what was in it.
Oh God,
I feel so foolish.
I feel like you're judging me.
And you're like,
no,
I'm not judging you.
Right.
No one was getting banged in a fucking Jacuzzi.
No one got it that way.
Did they?
Right.
No one went down to a,
what does that freak nick or what do they call that hedonism where everybody
goes down to that fucking the Haiti and fucks,
you know,
before the earthquake.
I guess I got to move it now.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Jamaica.
Is that where you go?
It's just fucking crazy,
you know?
Or they go down to Brazil.
He says,
I went to Brazil and banged a bunch of whores and I don't even know what I have.
I got,
I got south of the border,
fucking gonorrhea,
you know.
No one says that.
No one says that there was a Mariachi band and I was banging this girl in the
dirt outside some fucking bar and Tiawana and that's how I got syphilis.
No one says that.
It's always an innocent fucking story.
And they always look down and I think of course,
cause there's shame involved,
but no one will own up to it.
No.
Just say,
listen,
you know,
I banged a lot of broads and I went in Ra.
Alright,
no vest,
no fucking robber,
no nothing.
I stuck it in there,
move it around.
I got all up in that disease and now it's on my dick and I just thought you
should know.
I add my time.
I had a good fucking time and uh,
now I'm paying for it.
All right.
You want to help me limp across the fucking finish line of life with my
blistered cock?
Is that what you want to do?
If you're up for it,
I'm just trying to be up front.
What did you order by the way?
Did you,
did you start with a,
did you get the muscles?
Um,
no one says that shit.
Jesus bill,
we got it.
So last week I was talking about saying,
you know what,
they and I had to fuck a website for people with STD so they don't got to go
through this shit.
And Lo and behold,
they got one,
they got a fucking site here.
People,
let me see what we got here.
Somebody they got do,
they pretty much got a fucking website for everything.
And I remember there was a guy a few weeks ago,
this fucking dude over there,
he fucking called.
He called me up,
he fucking sent me an email and he was telling me that they,
uh,
10 most bizarre dating websites.
Oh,
I know what I was going to say.
I can't read and think at the same time.
How fucked up is that or think about something else.
I can't multitask.
Um,
this guy sent me this email and he was saying that,
uh,
Jesus to fuck what the fuck was my point.
See now my brain is looking at this shit.
My brain,
it works in a straight line and two shit gets erased immediately.
The fuck did he say
this is unbelievable?
Is this,
is this how Reagan started?
Um,
all right,
fuck it.
I don't know what the fuck he said.
Oh,
I remember where I got it now.
He was talking about how he didn't want to do the online dating thing cause he
thought it was like this whole stigma and that type of shit.
And he felt like a loser.
We're kind of guy can't go out and get laid or on his own and go meet a girl.
Fuck that.
If I was a young dude and my goddamned prime as opposed to a fucking approaching
the end of his middle age,
which I gotta be cause you mold 42 times two is 84 right?
You think I'm making 85 I got news for you.
I am.
I'm making a 101.
I'm going to see the seventies again.
2070 I'm checking out.
Um,
I'm calling it right here.
That's my prediction.
Knows to Domus on my own fucking life.
Did he ever do that with themself?
That arrogant prick.
Do knows the dominance is so fucking overrated.
It's ridiculous in new futures.
Bad Shit's going to happen.
Really?
There's going to be a guy with a beard.
Say something to a bald guy.
Oh my God,
Dude.
Dead Saddam.
That's Gorbachev.
No,
you know what that is?
That's like when you get your horoscope read.
When you say a bunch of vague shit,
believers,
dumb people,
kind of people who sit in a pulpit,
you know,
and just listened to another human being tells stories about three headed
fucking dogs.
You know the whole thing's that dog and pony show.
Why are those ceiling so high?
They're trying to intimidate you.
Why are you sitting on a piece of wood?
Huh?
They can't have sofas.
They don't want you to lounge and they want you to sitting upright.
All nervous.
Like what?
What's going to happen to me?
Just tell me what I need to do.
You know?
Then they walk up those stairs made out of marble,
right.
Stand up there when they preach.
Was that so they can see.
You can see him now so it can be a little bit higher and fucking talk down to
you as you sit on your fucking wooden bench with no cushion.
Sit Up straight.
I'm channeling a higher power right now.
All right.
Anyway,
so this fucking guy writes me and he said,
he says it's a stigma dude.
They got a website for fucking everything.
If I was in my prime,
if I could do it over,
I would be all over the fucking Internet.
So they,
they have a website.
Okay.
First of all,
they have,
they have a website for people with STDs,
which I think is a great thing.
Yeah,
let's keep it in house.
No awkward conversation.
Ah,
fucking,
you know,
and then you can be honest about how you got it.
Where'd you get yours?
I got mine in fucking Chile.
Dude,
I was in the combat zone getting blown on a flight of stairs.
Right.
I got one fucking,
I dunno if she fucking bit my ball bag.
I was into it and evidently she had rabies on one of her friends sizes.
Um,
all right.
So they got all these different fucking websites here.
10 most bizarre dating websites.
I feel like I should have Anton fig here right now to do a little drum roll.
Um,
they have a website for lookalikes,
people who look like each other,
which I think is awesome.
You know,
a couple of narcissists just get together and uh,
they don't have a day.
You know,
neither one of them has a problem with the other person is saying,
I need a little me time.
They're going to have me time together just looking at each other,
how they look alike.
Um,
this one basically says a look alike date dating website because that's where
we're all looking for,
right?
I'm the founder of,
uh,
find your face,
make.com.
So she,
she says that she was inspired to build a website after people kept telling her
that she and her ex husband look a lot alike.
It's really not a comment compliment then they had,
they have a website for ugly people.
I swear to God,
uh,
Britain's first dating agency,
who are the guests.
Britain would have a date,
a dating website for ugly people.
You know,
it's not that people in Britain are fucking ugly.
It's that they,
the country is the size of Michigan.
Uh,
you know,
Americans are good looking people because we got everybody.
Everybody's fucking,
everybody.
We were mulching it over.
You've got fresh soil over here.
Goddamn English people.
They've been fucking in the same soil for years.
Goddamn teeth are all fucked up.
You want to see the worst?
If I'm looking at the royal family,
is there good looking person?
Fergie.
Fergie could scare a fucking pug.
Okay.
She could.
She looks like,
I'm like,
I don't know what
you know if a poodle fucked Helen Keller,
that's what,
that's fucking me.
That's what you get.
You get Fergie and look at fucking look at Prince Charles.
Jesus Christ.
You know why his wife was 20 years younger than them?
Because that's how much further along he had to be intellectually to talk a
Brady fucking pretty woman in the bed.
Even with a Goddamn Castle,
Prince William.
I mean they just knocked the teeth that just horrific Harry with those beady
little eyes,
you know,
he looks like a,
like one on one of the guys in Dillinger's gang from fuck.
He looked like they have so just been fucking each other for so goddamn long.
Like,
Hey,
if you ever look at pictures of people like from 50 years ago,
you know,
they're probably doesn't work in England.
They probably look exactly the fucking same cause God knows you guys are still
fucking trying to empty that keg of DNA over there,
right?
But over here in America,
people look different because we had all these different ethnicities came in and
then everybody,
like people look really ethnic.
Like if you look at pictures of Americans and like the 20s at Italian people
looked Italian,
French people look French.
You could tell what country people were from.
And then by the 60s right after world war two,
everybody came back and just started fucking banging away.
Okay.
The greatest generation basically from their balls came the deuce generation
known as the baby boomers,
the whining,
crying,
patting yourself on the back.
Conti is most selfish self,
righteous generation we've ever fucking had.
They take credit for all the good shit and completely ignore that.
They're all a bunch of bank or cons.
Now,
driving fucking convertible BMWs right through the 80s right?
Right into AI g,
all those fucking people and they all claim they were at Woodstock and they
protested the fucking war.
Fuck all of them.
All right.
This is a night lot of generalities here.
So anyways,
but if you notice those people,
they they uh,
they look different.
You know,
I can't remember if my fucking point was,
I know point was it's fitting that England started ugly people.com.
Um,
what is it called?
It's called a the ugly,
the ugly bug.
ball.com.
A dating website.
All right.
You know,
it's funny,
the last time I said English people were ugly.
You know who they sent over is one of their good looking people was that chick
from the uh,
from the spice girls.
You know,
who in this country would just be the real,
uh,
the real housewife of uh,
orange county would that awful face lift.
She looks like a good look in mouse.
That's the best thing I'll give her.
I'm all right.
They got a sea captain website for sea captains for women who like guys who
fucking,
where that Ted Knight fucking a,
I have a yacht hat.
They got that.
Let me just blow through these.
They got a dead,
a dating website for a mothers single son.
Mothers playing matchmakers for their children is probably as old as humanity
itself.
Ladies,
you can't tell me that's not,
that's not a major red flag.
Okay.
If there's some mother,
like the kids got some sort of fucked up relationship that his mother's picking
that out the pussy,
that he's gonna Bang for the rest of his fucking life.
Do you think you're ever going to be dressed nice enough?
Do you think the house is ever going to be need enough?
Do you think your smores are ever going to taste as good as the wrinkled cunt
that this guy came out of?
I don't think they are.
So stay away from that website.
That's my advice for the ladies this week.
A website number five.
Um,
are you okay?
This one is a s for superheroes and Super Villian villains.
Are you lonely looking for a special someone?
Are you looking,
are you also okay with tights wearing crime fighters?
These fucking comic book people hear a bunch of freaks.
I think that that's what you start off doing when you start off dressing up like
a superhero.
Eventually you get into that porn where you want to fuck a mascot.
Um,
dating website for beautiful people.
That's a great one.
I think that's great.
I think beautiful people should fuck each other and just make more beautiful
people,
you know,
give the rest of us something to jerk off to,
or maybe something to claim if you go out and make your million when,
that'd be great.
Um,
dating website for pot smokers.
Tired of smoking weed alone.
Tried joining for 20 dating and pack that bowl for two.
And of course they have some super hot chick with a flat stomach.
Like she smokes weed.
She's not smoking weed.
She's doing coke.
That's how she keeps the fucking weight off.
Can't have a stomach that flat when you fucking eat a whole bag of jacks.
Um,
dating website for women behind bars,
dating website for married people,
old geesh.
Every 20 seconds summons someone.
Somebody new joins.
Ashley Madison's looking to have a discreet of fair life is short.
Have an affair with the trademark greeting like that on the homepage.
You can't say that the Ashley Madison Agency are shy when it comes to the fact
that they're dating websites caters specifically to married people with the
roving eye.
There's even the option to quickly visit a fake home renovation website at any
moment by pressing a panic button.
Wow.
And then number 10,
the drum roll from Anton fig is a dating website for people with STDs.
And it's a picture of two happy people that they're psyched that they both have.
Uh,
uh,
I think I'm out of funny.
Stds,
STDs.
Um,
connect with singles who share your STD.
That's a slogan from STD match.net.
Whether you're living with herpes,
HPV,
or anything else.
Notice how did they take to one scary one,
one kind of mainstream one and then the,
or anything else.
Um,
there's something,
there's someone there for you.
So there you go.
There you go.
People,
I think I just helped him make a love connection for a lot of you guys out
there.
Those are all the people you know,
there's somebody for people who smoke weed.
How about you should have an alcoholics one if you're sick as somebody fucking
ragged on yet to put down the God damn bottle,
not for four straight up alcoholics.
Because if you're straight up alcoholic rights,
you want to end the problem.
Yeah.
But just for somebody with somebody who fucking nags you all the time,
right?
You don't give a fuck that you have a beer belly.
All right?
You live for sports and you live for whatever seasonal AOL Sam Adams puts out.
And you want a giant glass and you want to just suck down like fucking 20 of
them.
And you just want to be able to do that without somebody judging you.
That'd be a great website.
That really would,
I would enjoy that one.
God Damn.
And I miss beer.
I really fucking miss that shit.
People.
I'm coming up on 200 days,
you know,
vanity vanity wise.
I'm loving it.
You know,
I'm in shape again.
And,
uh,
I,
Jesus,
I was out in fucking a Milwaukee and I was working the PAPP's theater and this
theater was from like,
uh,
the mid 18 hundreds,
like,
like Duke Ellington's band.
The original band played there.
Liberace,
who's from Wisconsin,
he played there.
All these amazing,
amazing fucking entertainers had played there.
And I'm sitting there doing my show and I went and phenomenal.
By the way,
I'm gonna tell you right now,
Milwaukee and Detroit are now in the rotation.
Without a doubt.
I was blown away by how many people showed up.
I was really nervous when my guy book both of those cities.
I didn't know how many people are going to show up.
I'd never done stand up in Milwaukee and I hadn't done the Royal Oak Theater in
seven years.
Last time I did there I was on the rich bitch tour,
uh,
with,
the Chappelle show tour with Charlie Murphy and Donnell Rawlings.
I was the first guy out of the gate.
Nobody knew who I was.
Everybody thought I was a writer on Chappelle show,
which I wasn't at a,
or they thought I was from the Detroit Metro area.
I was just some local white guy that they put on there and that way,
you know.
But anyways,
I'm ton of people fucking showed up and basically I forgot my point.
Oh,
I remember I was in Milwaukee and they had some beer that was some local beer
and I noticed it was a bunch of people from Milwaukee sucking them down and they
were all saying how good they are.
And that's one of the things I'd like to do is check out the local breweries and
now,
man,
that was a fucking rough one to not be able to do that at some point.
I'm going to end this street though.
Like when Brett Farve finally decided,
all right,
fuck it.
Well I guess he really didn't.
Somebody threw him on the ground like a rag doll and he said,
I can't do it.
I no,
that's how his career ended.
Like cal Ripkin,
cal Ripken took himself out of the lineup.
I'm going to do that at some point.
Um,
but anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
Let's get,
let's get to some of the questions is some of the comments from last week's
podcast,
somebody that some lady wrote in,
I was talking about always wear a condom and you can't believe the information
this lady sends in without anything else.
She goes,
I'm a nurse and you can actually still get herpes using a condom.
Just an FYI.
That's it.
No telling you how you can get herpes by using.
How can you get hurt?
How can you get a herpes using a condom
if you take a condom,
you unroll that motherfucker all the way down the shaft of your cock.
Get it all the way down to the base and it doesn't break and you never dip your
Dick in pass where the fucking condoms she never ride.
Yeah.
Nothing drips down on you and nothing.
How does it,
what does it eat through the rubber.
Okay,
you're teasing me here lady.
You got me.
I'm on the hook.
I'm signed up for the sequel for the love of God.
Tell me how the fuck you can get herpes wearing a god damn condom.
That's,
that's frightening.
They didn't say that in health class.
That sounds like some shit.
I never took a health class.
Oh my kid.
You know what is staggering is I don't know anything about the vagina.
I don't know anything about it.
Somebody said cervix the other day and they kept talking about their cervix and
I don't even know what it was and evidently that's like the swinging saloon door
that the baby comes out.
I don't know what ovaries are.
Aren't there like two of them and that's,
they spit out a couple of eggs.
I don't know anything about him.
There's a tube in there.
The eggs come down the tube or one egg comes down the tube and if you don't
knock it up then it,
it Kinda just withers up and then just to bloody mess once a month is now works.
I don't,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Like if you're ever in an elevator and was stuck and you start having a kid,
you're in trouble because I don't know anything.
I don't anything when it wipe out anything when it comes to that shit,
I never took a fucking health class.
And for some reason the amount of stuff that fascinates me,
the reproductive aspects of a vagina don't fascinate me.
I was just more interested in the,
uh,
the clitoris and a,
what do I have to do on the inside to try to make the same reaction happen.
Other than that,
I was good with the other stuff.
It's kind of like me with cars,
you know,
I can change the oil change and air filter.
I can take up the radiator out and replace the pumps.
But you know,
you start getting in with the Pistons and I don't know shit,
I don't know anything about it.
Taking that to somebody else.
I thought she's,
uh,
she's told nerve or stomach here,
I'll be in the waiting room.
Let me tell you guys that I have no plans.
If I ever have a kid to be in the fucking delivery room,
I'm not going to go in there and get yelled at.
You know,
having some woman break my fucking finger as I'm standing there doing what?
What am I doing except adding to the heat in the room just by my body
temperature and the,
I can't do anything.
Stand in their dress like like a fucking surgeon.
Like I know.
I don't know anything.
Goddamn pussy guys,
man.
Just getting talked into one fucking thing after another.
Back in the day you stood out in the waiting room where you belonged.
Yeah.
Let's bring somebody else in here.
Somebody else in the year who has germs,
you know to breathe on the Goddamn kid.
I don't want to see it when it comes out.
When it's not ready yet,
hose it off.
Slap it around,
make sure everything's fine,
then bring it out.
Eh,
are you doing their sport?
Patted on its soft head handouts,
some cigars and then go up there and wipe the sweat off my wife's brow.
That's why I wanted to do it.
Old School did.
Evidently if you do that,
you're the worst first person on the planet.
I can't wait for that to swing back.
Kind of like with like eggs.
You know,
when I was a kid,
eggs were healthy and then all of a sudden everybody said,
all you got to eat as the white stuff.
You eat the yolk and then all of a sudden that,
that it gives you a heart attack and then a fucking swung back again.
Oh,
wait,
the yolks.
Okay.
That's what I'm hoping for.
It's going to swing back again.
That's when I'll have a kid when I could stand out smoking a fucking cigar,
you know,
just sitting there with the fucking cigar in my mouth and a.com.
Dot.
[inaudible] all right.
Why are you here?
What?
Our girl out a girl choir,
right?
Everybody's smoking out Kroger.
I'll cry.
Don't worry.
Tell I want to do it.
I know there's a lot of women like you should never be a parent.
Um,
whatever.
Probably shouldn't.
Okay,
Bill,
you should come back and check out the Clinton Museum here in Little Rock.
Oh yeah.
Last week I talked about the Reagan Library and how we had a great time.
You said Arkansas sucks are only bragging rights are Clinton and Walmart and the
razorbacks SCC football.
What are you talking about?
So the Clinton Museum has to be decked out to overcompensate.
Oh,
I see.
Whenever you come down,
I'll tell you some,
uh,
some more old redneck sangs.
My friends can take you out hunting.
There's a funny bone down here,
uh,
to that can be your ticket.
So that could be a ticket.
Little Typo there.
Um,
you know,
a lot of people are going to take me up on that hunting thing.
Um,
I just got to figure out who's not a psycho.
I mean that,
that was pretty well written.
But you're also from Arkansas.
I guess that's going to be par for the course,
right?
I don't want to go hunting and Rhode Island.
I want the real deal.
Arkansas is a good state.
I wonder what do I want to shoot?
I want to shoot a varmint.
Let me start small.
I don't want to shoot like a badger or a wolverine.
How about a raccoon
shooter?
Right in its belly
possum something fucking ugly.
Uh,
number three.
Hey Bill.
Uh,
as a woman,
I fucking hate to hear bitches.
Oh,
wait a minute.
I'm supposed to do on my catchphrases this week.
People gave me some catch phrases.
Let me try out a couple of these catch phrases.
You guys tell me if you like them or not.
Um,
where the fuck are they?
All right.
Instead of saying get her done,
you could say got a Prius,
a comically insane.
That's a catchphrase,
ginger and loving it.
Securing my perimeter.
You know what?
That could be the name of a special in the late eighties,
if I was already a dad and it was talking about having a man cave,
if I could come out with that before Tim Allen came out with that pegboard and
did tool time,
I think,
I think I could've made a Zillion,
I don't read no research necessary.
Some of these are actually a doable,
oh,
if I finish a joke after every joke,
I could go on [inaudible] ginger,
how would you guys like that?
He's a fucking horrific.
These are all and your career catch phrases.
You just got billed.
Burned.
All right,
I'm going to Puke if I read any more of these.
Um,
alright,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
bill is a woman.
I fucking hate to hear bitches complain about being stay at home,
a stay at home.
Mom,
are you kidding me?
It will be the greatest gig ever.
I get to garden,
Cook,
go shopping,
watch Netflix all day.
But mostly,
I can't believe this is written by a woman,
but mostly not have to get up and work at 7:00 AM every fucking day and work
with a bunch of bitches that I can't stand.
Even the Goddamn Jim has a babysitter to watch your spawn while your workout.
Great Point.
Then you go meet your girlfriends for three Martini lunch,
then run by whole foods,
foods in the liquor store and go home and fix a gin and tonic while you get
dinner ready and then give your man some hot,
steamy sex when he gets home.
Is it that hard to push a baby carriage around and then let that thing suck on
your team every once in awhile?
No,
it can't be.
I am not a mom,
but I have a dog.
That's hilarious.
I was gonna say,
this sounds like a guy.
I can't believe a woman wrote this.
Um,
I just completely agree with you on this subject.
Quit whining and learn and learn how to keep your legs shut if he can handle it.
Anyways,
I love the podcast.
Thanks for doing it.
Come to Louisiana soon please.
I'm planning on it in the fall for an Lsu game.
So there you go ladies.
That's coming from one year old,
a sellout,
you might say,
all right,
let's get to advice here and then I got,
I gotta wrap this shit up really quickly.
Uh,
wait,
can you please keep Trev with the puppet?
The um,
oh by the way,
you guys,
why don't you guys vote on the,
on your catch phrase and I'll say it once next week when I do the whatever funny
joke you want me to say.
Got a Prius.
Like get her done.
Get a Prius.
You like that?
Do you want me to say ginger and loving it?
Securing my perimeter or a what was the last one?
Ah,
ginger vote on the Mlm,
podcast.com.
I could have sold those a lot better.
I know.
I always promise my web guy that I'm going to sell this shit better.
And I just,
you know,
what is this podcast,
the stream of consciousness.
So if I try and plan shit,
it ends up not being funny.
Let's get to the advice here,
but please go there and please go to the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Check out the youtube videos for the week.
Um,
if you want to email me questions,
please send it at a something,
some off.
I kind of know what the hell it is.
What is the email?
It's on the MM podcast.com.
What the fuck is at Jesus Christ?
Why do I try,
why do I get my web guy right now is just throwing his hands up in the fucking
air and that's what he's saying.
Why do I try to help this guy?
This is pointless.
Thank God for the donation button.
Um,
anyways,
advice for the week.
Uh,
I haven't read any of these.
Whatever I flew today,
people go fuck yourselves.
I haven't read any of these Salami.
Uh,
let me blow through this.
Um,
it by advice.
You know what I should've done?
I should've got a joke book and just read bad jokes and then,
then tried out the fucking catchphrases.
That's what I should've done.
God dammit.
All right.
Advice bills.
Since you've,
uh,
you've given great advice and relationships in the past the morning.
If he can do it for me.
I've been with this girl,
this lady of mine for years and we're planning on getting married.
Oh,
Geez.
Uh,
we're both only 20 years old.
I'm a college dropout since I'm certainly a more blue collar individual.
She is going to college to work with children.
We both work full time jobs,
mind being the night shift in a warehouse,
selecting orders to go to individual stores,
stressful and physically challenging.
Uh,
here's being her as being a phone,
answering day job from eight to five,
working with customers in a graphic design shop.
Boring and easy.
Okay.
He's defined.
His job is stressful and physically challenging and her job is boring and easy.
Never underestimate how tedious and boring job can be.
I'd rather do your job walking around breaking balls.
Look at his fucking shirt,
dude.
Fucking queer drive by on the fucking forklift,
right guys,
start a softball league.
You have a great time.
Rather than sitting there having your ass fall asleep in a cubicle listening to
people bitch,
cause they can't figure out how to work their,
set it and forget it.
Grass is always greener,
my friend.
Why don't I shut my fucking pie hole and read the rest of this?
All right.
Since we started dating,
she seemed to do everything to keep me interested.
Uh,
make me breakfast in the mornings
on some,
on some days,
go to concerts with me when she didn't necessarily like the music.
Um,
the whole works.
But I've noticed that she without shoes,
without question,
just been lacking in the care department.
She just sits and watches TV every night and eats and complains about gaining
weight.
I come home in the morning to do dirty dishes,
to do the dirty dishes that piled up in the sink from her having friends over
while I'm at work for the night and get yelled at for not cleaning them.
Well when I saw them sitting there,
but I had no part in making them dirty dude.
What the fuck?
You can't have that.
She leaves clothes laying around every room in the house and that's not even how
uh,
she is with me.
She has seemed to develop some kind of self righteousness where everything that
she wear,
everything that she,
yeah dude,
I really got to proof read these people.
So many spelling mistakes,
mistakes.
She has seemed to develop some kind of self righteousness where everything that
she says throughout the day should be my main concern and I should go out of my
way to make her life easier.
I do her college homework.
I take care of the $2,000 dog I bought for.
I work on a car when,
when she nearly runs the damn wheels off the thing and I do chores for her
family.
She volunteers me for two.
She has your balls and a little that you know,
that little engagement ring your butter if you bother yet your balls are in
there to the next part is the icing on the cake.
She goes as far as to dictate what time after go to bed and wake up in the
morning.
Um,
he uh,
evening since I work at nights,
uh,
what,
what I can and can't spend money on,
who I can hang out with,
what days I can see friends and require me to call her every time I arrive at
work in texture in the middle of the night when I get off work and request her
and I requested to do nothing outside of what she does on her day to day
routine.
To sum all that up,
I feel like she's forcing me into a cookie mold guy when I actually let her make
her own decisions.
Like some strange thing called an adult.
All right,
I'm going to stop right here dude.
Cause this is just going to be more fucking misery.
All right.
This is,
this is what I've said this before on the podcast.
You have to,
I don't give a fuck how good the woman is that you're with.
You really have to be careful because all this shit you see on TV where women
are just constantly,
there's all this fucking information out there about how guys are assholes to
women.
There's just reams of it.
And there needs to be,
because guys are assholes to women.
So women I think are more aware,
or at least they should be more aware because he got all these fucking goddamn
shows with either from one to four twats sitting around bitching about guys and
all this shit that we do.
But there's no show on TV where you four guys just sitting around a coffee
table,
you know,
drinking some hot cocoa with some pillows and wearing sweaters in their favorite
shoes.
Talking about,
you know,
not losing yourself in a relationship.
That's what you've done here.
All this shit that she's doing is your fault.
Okay.
And what's great about being a guy who she can blame the victim,
which is why we're better problem solvers.
All right?
This is your fault.
This is all on you.
You don't like any of this shit.
You have to sit down and talk to her,
okay?
You,
you,
you're not required to call her.
You can go to bed when you fucking want to go to bed and you can just sit there
and tell it you did those dishes.
You clean it up,
okay?
Now,
here's the point.
This is the key with brides.
This is what you gotta do.
You can't be mean.
There's no reason to be mean here.
There's no reason to yell.
There's no reason to be angry,
okay?
All three of those things is what she wants you to do because the cause,
she knows she's going to know she's fucking wrong.
If you,
if you,
if you made the dishes dirty and every day you're telling me to clean them up,
you treat me like I'm fucking Alison the Goddamn Brady Bunch.
Everybody knows that that's fucking wrong.
So what women do when they're fucking wrong is they try to make the argument
about something else.
All right?
So she's going to do that anyways.
So,
but you're going to make it easy.
If you're angry and you yell at her.
And you call her fucking names.
So what you gotta do?
What you gotta.
You gotta keep,
keep your fucking cool.
That's what you gotta do.
Keep your fucking cool and say,
listen,
I worked all night.
I don't think it's fair that you tell me to come home and I have to do these
dishes.
When you made these dishes dirty yourself,
I don't think it's fair to me to come home in the morning and have a sink full
of dirty tissues that not only you,
you and your friends may dirty.
That's unacceptable to me that you want me to wash those.
That's unacceptable.
I'm not doing it.
You have to wash those.
I'll wash my dirty dishes.
I'm not doing that.
All right,
and then,
then let her flip out.
Let her power.
Let her slam the fucking cabinets.
Let her not fuck you.
Just don't back down.
Rub One out.
Who gives a fuck?
It's just an urge.
You've already banged her.
You're not missing anything.
Who gives a fuck but don't get angry.
All right,
and then just do due to her what she did to you.
Just just reclaim that territory.
You're not doing that.
You're not doing that anymore.
All right.
Start with the fucking dishes and then start with this.
I know and you know,
you can actually tag that argument and just say,
now that we're on this topic of discussing things,
I'm going to go to bed when I want to go to bed.
I just,
it makes me feel like a child when you're telling me when to go to bed.
I know when to go to bed.
All right.
Now that I've air two complaints,
how about you give me a couple of,
you got anything you want to say to me and just stay cool.
Then when she hit you with some shit,
if you don't like it,
tell her,
you know,
I was going to say to go fuck herself to,
I don't know what,
whatever.
Do you know what?
Fuck that last advice.
Just go with the dishes thing first.
It's unacceptable.
That's it.
If you bring up something else,
then you'd then,
it looks like you have all this resentful shit and then she'll try and spin it
like,
yeah,
well if you're feeling all this,
why didn't you fucking say thing cuts?
You're your con.
That's what's going to happen.
And then you're going to lose the argument and then next thing you know to make
up for it,
you're not going to be getting any pussy from her.
And you can be doing a whole sink full of fucking dishes that you didn't dirty.
All right,
moving on.
But sir,
you have all the power there.
Just keep your fucking cool.
All right,
next one and then I gotta wrap this up.
This podcast is getting way too fucking long lately.
A subject.
Whose Dick do I have to suck to be a stay at home mom?
Bill Jesus.
Here's another one,
Bill.
I've been with my girlfriend for a year and a half now.
I love her to death.
We have a fundamental problem.
I'm a sports nut.
I watch every single bills game and almost every sabers game.
I played high school hockey,
college hockey,
and now that I'm in the real world,
uh,
beer league hockey twice a week.
My girlfriend who was a good family life with both parents,
grew up with an older brother that played hockey with an,
with an entire family that is just as ridiculous of sports fans as I am.
She is a super,
super girly girl that never got into it.
And since she was dragged to all of her brothers hockey's games and hated it,
she now absolutely hates sports in any kinds of sports viewing activity.
All right.
That's understandable.
This is causing and yeah.
Unbelievable amount of friction lately.
Now that the honeymoon stage of our relationship is over,
she used to come.
Uh,
I used to come along to my hockey games,
come with me to,
uh,
my Superbowl parties and group outings at sports bars on Sundays during the
football game.
Now she absolutely refuses to do anything related to sports whatsoever.
I wouldn't really care that much,
but I hang out with a ton of other couples and I'm always alone.
Now W uh,
whenever I want to watch a game
bill,
you're a sports fan.
It's a lot more fun to watch a game with the other buffalo fans than to watch a,
to watch it alone.
Yeah.
Uh,
okay.
My brain's tired.
I'm sorry guys who was there to hear all that shit you spew at the TV when
you're watching it alone.
Uh,
nobody in my Nia hate sports.
You know,
she likes going to basketball games.
She likes going to football games and looking at the field and then she's not
into it.
So I,
you know,
all right,
dude,
I already know where you're going with this.
I love this girl.
He says,
I want to work with it.
We are a perfect fit.
Every other act I talked to her about the sports thing.
It's really becoming increasingly a big deal,
but she would not budge on this whole sports vendetta.
What's,
as a sports fan do when he finds himself in this situation?
All right,
well this is what you got to do.
This is a great thing.
Okay.
When you're in a relationship,
you do have to have areas that you're into and the other person isn't.
So you can get the fuck away from each other.
Absence makes the heart fonder.
All right?
So what I would do right now is your basically doing to her what her family
already did,
which is you're not in as bad,
but you're trying to force into this shit.
She doesn't want to do it.
She wants to have her own life.
So let her have her own life.
All right.
And you do your fucking sports thing.
And uh,
she does her thing.
You do your thing and then when there's a big game coming up,
you got to do something that's gonna make it fun for her.
Either a great to do some other activity with her if she comes to the sports
thing or you can fucking turn it into like a date night thing is gay is that
sounds,
um,
you just have it built around rather than some awful fucking romantic comedy
movie.
You have it built around the Sabres game.
You've got to do something to make it fun for her.
But right now you know what she needs to do.
She needs the detox from sports.
You just don't force it on her and just find some other activity that you guys
like doing,
going to the gym or some other shit.
Looking at the fucking ducks.
I don't know what,
find something that you guys can do together and then you watch the sports and
she goes and goes to her needle point fucking class,
whatever the hell she wants to do.
Maybe that's what you do.
I can tell you right now,
all your buddies who's broads are going to them with the fucking games
eventually are going to be envious of the fact that you can go to a goddamn
sports bar by yourself and they don't have their ball and chain.
Cause eventually most of their relationships are going to suck and they're gonna
want to get a divorce and that they're just going to be miserable,
you know?
And then they won't communicate and they'll gradually keep getting fatter and
fatter because they just going to be drowning themselves in appetizers and
beers.
That's basically what's going to happen.
So you actually have a decent situation.
Um,
I'm a total sports,
not a Nia hate sports.
She doesn't give a fuck.
So,
uh,
when she watches reality TV,
I go out and do stand up.
And,
uh,
when I watch sports,
she goes out,
works out,
it goes out and fucking it goes,
hangs with her friends or goes in the other room.
That's it.
And I watch it with my dog and it,
and it's worked out.
So there you go.
And I think that's it.
I think that's the podcast for this week.
A,
I've got a couple of youtube videos,
how they make the ice rink.
They got a couple of good videos like this.
This,
we'll send you to some links.
How to make a backyard ice rank,
which is something I've always dreamed of doing.
You know,
back in the day when I thought I was going to be a dad and have four fucking
kids,
you know,
three boys and a girl.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't let the girls play hockey though.
You know what I mean?
I wouldn't let him do that.
You know,
I just wouldn't,
it's just too,
uh,
you know,
if I had a girl,
I,
I'd send her like to,
uh,
how to make a grilled cheese sandwich like class.
You know,
I really want to bring back the America that I've read about,
you know,
the chauvinist stick a fucking with you guys.
Um,
here's another one.
Eating fish alive.
I don't even know what this one is.
Is this something about Asia?
Okay.
There was a fish on a plate and it looks like it's waving.
Like please,
please,
we'll be back in the water on this chop sticks.
What a surprise.
Those little dishes you put the thing that is the fucking worst thing I've ever
seen
stabbing with the fucking stick you asshole.
Okay.
They just eat the ginger around it.
You know what,
what is with the continent of Asia when it comes to animals that you know,
I know we do cruel shit in this country,
but they just fucking go above and beyond.
You guys ever see that movie?
The cove?
I never had the balls to watch it.
It's basically about Japanese people club and dolphins to death.
Not all of them,
but just some people.
I'm not sure saying that Asia is a bad place,
you know,
look at us with their guns is a lot of shit that we do that's probably fucking
stupid.
But
how do you,
how do you do that fucking,
I think it's just sitting there and moving.
It's fin.
I Dunno.
By the way,
somebody sent me an email that went above and beyond.
This is some extra time here on the podcast.
Uh,
th this one is beyond my advice.
By the way.
This guy basically sent me an email.
He said,
ah,
I was good friends with this.
This was female.
Uh,
we've known each other since my freshman year at the University of Blah,
blah,
blah.
And the year 2000,
we keep in contact.
She's like my kid sister.
And I thought this was going to be like,
she's like my kid sister,
but he really had like a crush on her.
Um,
so when you,
but it isn't,
it goes,
takes a total left turn.
He says,
uh,
we all keep in contact.
My whole crew or college friends,
we all keep in contact and we meet as much as possible.
Um,
the girl who's my kid sister,
she went to the Peace Corps in 2008 and she got a boyfriend who left the peace
corps early to be with her.
And this guy says,
I don't like this guy to put a tersely.
He's done.
He's done nothing to warrant any antagonism,
but he's just never set well with me.
I've kept it to myself because they love quote each other and he has never set a
foot wrong,
um,
with me or even my friends.
In fact,
he is overly attentive to her.
I have never seen a my kid,
sister friend,
they're so attached to her boy to a boyfriend.
Last holiday,
we all got together and some of us noticed a marked change in my girlfriend.
My,
I'm trying not to name her name,
let's just call her Lisa.
Lisa's demeanor.
She's usually very bright,
bubbly,
and vivacious girl.
A type of girl who wasn't the prettiest in the room,
but could catch any man's attention with their Cham and personality.
Now she has an insecure,
negative mopey introverted attitude.
She marked it down.
Oh,
she,
she tried to say it was her graduate school stress,
but this was,
but she was this way for an entire week.
This past Sunday,
another friend in the group will call her Susie and I were arranging plans in
late May to go to mobe.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
And they stated that Lisa and her boyfriend might go.
Then the bomb came.
She let it slip that the real reason her boyfriend left the peace corps was
because he was a teacher and beat up a six year old kid in school.
He didn't leave the peace corps because of Lisa.
He left because he was asked to leave.
Um,
Lisa specifically told the rest not to mention it because of how I uh,
oh to me,
because how I would react since the incident was a misunderstanding.
I lived with an abusive father and she knows the story would put them in a bad
light.
And I realized immediately why didn't like this,
why there's Douche didn't sit well with me.
You reminded me of my father.
So it goes on to continue.
It gets really dark here where basically they think that this guy thinks that
she's being physically abused or whatever.
Dude,
this is a doctor drew question.
All right.
This is my advice called doctor drew call love line.
He will know exactly what the fuck to do if not to send you in the right
direction.
Uh,
the name of the show is love line.
you can find it and the guy's super famous.
I don't have the link here,
but uh,
yeah,
guys don't,
don't,
don't ask me questions like that because that is,
I'll ask the silly ones.
I like sports and she doesn't like,
but that is above and beyond,
you know,
this podcast and my ability to answer questions like that,
I feel fucking horrific.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I mean,
I say a lot of fucking horrific shit about women on here,
but I'm obviously just fucking around.
This is all comedy and stuff.
Like,
uh,
I have no idea how I would approach that,
but,
uh,
you know,
I,
all I can tell you is that a,
I've known somebody that was in a situation like that,
and it's hard when they're in the denial and protecting their Douche of a
fucking boyfriend and they won't fucking own up to it.
It's,
it's kind of an impossible
situation until they finally admit that they got a fucking problem.
Uh,
so I don't know,
it's above and beyond me what a fucked up way to end the podcast.
But I wanted to at least try to send this guy in the right direction because
that's a,
it was just a creepy fucking email.
So,
uh,
yeah,
so don't send me the creepy emails everybody.
I,
uh,
I'm flattered that someone would think that I could possibly know what the fuck
to do.
They're calling the love line for the serious ones,
the silly,
stupid ones,
you know,
I love her better.
Clam stinks.
You know,
those are the ones from me.
So that's the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
We're going to have another podcast this week.
I'm going to put it up.
Uh,
possibly Tuesday or Wednesday,
I'll announce it on the MM podcast this week where I actually,
I'll put it up on Wednesday.
Let's have a defined Wednesday,
will be a special edition of the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
and I'll have special guests,
uh,
Robert Kelly and Joe to Rosa,
and we're going to be talking about a film,
uh,
in the Tribeca film festival,
the film called cheat.
We're going to talk about how we all know each other.
We're gonna tell old stories.
We're going to break each other balls,
probably trash each other,
and
it might hurt our friendships,
but it's going to be hilarious.
Do you guys,
I hope you enjoy it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
Actually,
no,
I'll talk to you on Wednesday.
See Ya.
So you've painted,
so
[inaudible] you say you met me
every time I walk away,
and this goes on and on and off.
[inaudible] [inaudible] staff
or
changed your life
without a
[inaudible].
Good.
Is that,
so you've painted yourself n two O
and you
hang on
[inaudible] [inaudible]
oh,
so Ronan to
cod between
and no,
[inaudible].